Tianran: From calorie
count to portion sizes,
we wanted to find all the differences
between McDonald's in the US and China.
This is "Food Wars."
New season, USA versus China.
I'm so excited for you guys to see this
and to meet our new cohost, Tianran.
USA versus China, let's go.
Drinks from McDonald's in
China come in three sizes,
small, medium, and big.
But for some reason the
medium is 444 milliliters,
which in Chinese basically
just means die, die, die,
which is just super unlucky,
so I guess they really
want you to either get
the large or the small.
The drinks at a US
McDonald's come four sizes,
the extra small, where'd it go?
Sorry, they forgot it.
The small, the medium, and the large.
Our large is 80.9% bigger
than China's largest soda.
Let's see if that's true.
Bound to be a little bit in the lid.
That is blasphemous!
Shame these people. Shame this clown.
Some of you over the past several years
have said something to the tune of,
it doesn't count or it's wrong
because we add the ice, or
we keep the ice in there,
and that isn't a true measurement,
which I don't believe, but fine.
For the first time ever,
I want to measure this without the ice.
I'm solving this once and for all.
So, right away you get even less soda.
Let's get this up to
exactly 32 fluid ounces.
32 ounces of Coca-Cola
in the supposed 32-ounce McDonald's cup.
I'm so sick of this.
Why are they saying 32 fluid ounces?
Look! Just say 30 or 31. It's fine.
Your move, McDonald's.
Our fries come in three sizes:
small, medium, and large.
American fries come in three sizes:
We will now weigh our largest fry.
So, what about McNuggets?
Here in China, you can only get them
as an order of five or 10,
which is really just two portions of five.
That's cute, China. Real cute.
Here in the US, we have way
many more nugget options.
Four-piece, for your infant,
six-piece, 10-piece, 20-piece,
and our largest, the 40-piece.
All the mathheads watching
will be quick to point out
that this is 300% of
China's largest portion.
So, here are all the McDonald's
menu items from China
that you won't find in the US.
Here are all the
McDonald's items in the US
you won't find in China.
Oh, my God, I've been
staring at this for so long.
This is incredible. Check out the back!
It's an origami apple! This is the best.
Let's see what we got.
A hamburger, mini fries,
a drink, a corn cup.
[gasps] Dun-dun-dun!
Po!
Oh, my God, this is way
better than the Hamburglar.
What? do I have to build Po as well?
This is -- [laughs] I'm too old for this.
Anyway, if you don't want a hamburger,
you can also change this
out for a fish fillet
or for four pieces of nuggets.
You can also get the corn cup
changed out for apple slices,
but they will cost you 1 kuai extra.
And with the juice, you can
have either apple juice,
milk, or water.
So only healthy options
here in China's McDonald's.
OK, now on to the toy.
So, this is going to take
a while. Give me a second.
Ugh.
And then something flips
out from behind his groin.
In here! It's coming together!
Oh!
It's a basketball hoop.
Oh, my God, this is ingenuity at its best.
Look, we can play hoops with this.
Three, two, one!
Whoa!
I noticed that his Happy
Meal, even the box was a toy.
In America, our Happy Meal box
is another opportunity
for an advertisement.
All-new season of "The Masked
Singer" on Fox. Check it out.
Jesus, they're shameless. These kids.
Remember before, the
extra-small fry? Found it.
More nuggets, a four-piece.
Apple slices.
Our toy is decidedly not a puzzle.
Remember when Kermit
the Frog was in there?
That was weird.
OK, what is this?
Who? What celebrity was the fox?
Oh, it was Wayne Brady.
OK, I've heard of him.
What, is his head in here?
Oddly enough, shows the stark difference
between China and the US.
Theirs has this puzzle to put together,
ours is an ad for a TV show.
[laughs and cries]
OK, so these are our
exclusive beef burgers.
Here in China, people mostly eat pork,
so I think with the beef
they've really had to
go the premium route,
so you've got some
interesting combinations.
This is the German sausage
double beef burger,
but in Chinese the name is kind of like
the "anti-vegetarian tyrant."
So they've got some pretty
aggressive marketing for this.
Imagine Terry Crews just
pulsing his pecks while he --
what is that?
Ugh.
If this is what they
call a German sausage,
then I think the Germans
will be very angry.
Here we've got a BLT double beef burger.
I'm so sad. What is this?
This is like a BLT sandwich
that's been sat at the bottom
of your bag for a week.
I'm excited about these, though.
These are the Angus
max thick beef burgers.
Now, McDonald's have done
premium collaborations
with Michelin-starred chefs in the past,
and they even have these
really super-fancy packaging.
Look at that. Double cheeseburger.
Oh, wow! Look at that.
The meat patty is thicker than my thumb.
That's a proper burger.
Mm.
Well, it's very meaty. Incredibly cheesy.
This is the double cheeseburger,
so I can understand that.
For the vast majority of Chinese people,
their understanding or
access to Western food
may really come from
fast-food restaurants.
So this is probably the
gourmet burger experience
for the vast majority of
the Chinese population.
In the US, you can get a
Quarter Pounder with cheese.
What the heck? They gave us two tops?
This is the special two-top
Quarter Pounder with cheese, apparently.
And we also have a double Quarter Pounder,
if you want to increase the meat.
If someone wants to get
their daily vegetables,
here is the Quarter
Pounder with cheese deluxe.
Swimming in mayonnaise.
We have something in the United
States called the McDouble.
If you want slightly less
cheese on a double cheeseburger,
we got you covered.
Quarter Pounder with bacon.
Every once in a while, they
just take a Quarter Pounder
and put bacon on it,
and they repackage it for a celebrity.
And these are our exclusive
chicken and fish options.
So, I want to start you off with this,
which has since become
McDonald's best spicy burger.
This is the McSpicy chicken fillet.
Apparently it's 1,000 SHU,
which is a Scoville unit,
and it's roughly equivalent
to the spiciness you get
from a spicy and numbing hot pot,
and those guys are pretty spicy.
Mm. Oh, that's delicious.
You don't feel the burn at first,
and then it's like your tongue
slowly starts to wake up,
and it's like a frog in a pot.
It slowly starts to realize
it's being boiled alive,
and by the end of this burger,
you're going to want that Coke.
Now, this is McDonald's
best-selling non-spicy burger,
the grilled chicken sandwich,
which supposedly has no growth hormones
in their chicken feed.
Very heavy on the black
pepper. Oh. Ooh, wow.
I'm very excited about this.
This is the McCrunch
chicken fillet burger,
and in Chinese the name is "katsusui."
It sounds like how it's supposed to taste.
"Ka" is kind of like "crunchy,"
and "tsu" is kind of like
the juice kind of squirting out.
So this should be both crunchy and juicy.
Ooh, that looks like a much
better piece of chicken.
Yes, yes.
I didn't get the "ka,"
probably because this has gone a bit cold,
but look at that. It is juicy in there.
OK, this is the
super-spicy chicken fillet.
Look at this guy!
You know this is going to
be super spicy. It's orange!
It's not that spicy.
[coughs] Ooh!
It's not as -- oh!
Oh, my God.
Very tasty.
Finish that, and it's
to the hospital you go. Whew.
And last but, in my opinion,
least, the double fish burger.
Chicken sandwiches.
There's something that is new-ish,
the bacon ranch McCrispy.
Hm.
It's just OK.
There's also a bacon
ranch deluxe McCrispy,
where deluxe equals more vegetables.
The McCrispy is something that
we ordered and they forgot.
And then now, piling on the vegetables,
you got the McCrispy deluxe.
Spicy McCrispy.
So they just rebranded the
crispy chicken sandwich
to be the McCrispy?
How spicy can this be?
This is not spicy at all.
So, McDonald's China has one roll option,
which is this crispy pork and
pickled bamboo shoot wrap.
Mm.
That's tasty. It's nice and crunchy.
Very spicy! [laughs] Wow.
Mm.
It's spicy. It's sour.
Anything that has Sichuan peppercorn in it
is just incredible.
Here we've got the McSpicy wings,
which come in portions of two, four,
or nine.
Straight up, I wish we had those wings.
Those wings look really good.
Also, I don't know if you've noticed,
but the decoration here on the packet,
this is a collaboration
with a streetwear brand
called Clot, or C-L-O-T,
and it uses traditional
Chinese aesthetics.
So here you've got the lucky knot,
which is sort of like a symbol
for good luck and longevity.
As Chinese as it gets.
And this is also the same
flavor as the McSpicy burger.
I don't know if there's an
accurate translation for this.
This is literally called
"such a big chicken chop."
It's about the same size as
my palm, a little bit bigger.
The McCrispy chicken.
Mm. Crispy, wow.
Mm, yes!
This is very special.
We didn't think we'd be
able to get this today.
This is the
spicy lobster-flavored chicken tenders.
The Chinese says "yao yao,"
which means you have to shake it.
Oh, let's try these babies.
There was no need to shake it at all.
There's no seasoning there at all.
It's just literally chicken tenders.
It's more of an aspiration
towards lobster, though.
And we've got crinkle-cut fries.
Oh, how I've missed you.
Mm. Nothing beats a crinkle-cut fry.
In China, we have a bunch
of different barrel options.
For example, this one is
the Golden Arches bucket,
which actually didn't come in a bucket,
they just put everything into a box.
The name actually is the
reason why we got this,
because McDonald's in China
has officially renamed to Jingongmen,
which literally translates
as Golden Arches,
and when they did that
they caught a lot of flak.
Everybody started laughing at them.
Nobody calls them the
Golden Arches in Chinese.
It's just McDonald's.
But legally they are now
known as the Golden Arches.
Featuring sauces, you know
what that means, Yuelei.
Sauce talk.
Here are all of our exclusive sauces.
Garlic chili.
That's pretty much it.
Oh, and no Sichuan sauce, either.
That's an American invention,
just like General Tso's chicken.
But here in China, you
don't really get sauces
unless you ask for them.
They come with the nuggets.
Chinese people expect food to be complete
when it arrives at your table.
You don't go and add more sauce to it.
Sauces. In the United
States, optimal for dipping.
Tangy barbecue. Spicy Buffalo.
It's the USA, so you
know we got that ranch.
Honey mustard.
Honey, which is not here.
I don't know where it is.
Mayonnaise, which also
they did not include.
Mexican-style salsa.
These are our exclusive desserts.
I am going to try every
single one of them.
We can start with the taro pie.
Taro is kind of like a cross
between sweet potato and potato.
It's often used in desserts in Asia.
You'll find them in everything
from pies to bubble tea.
It's a bit like yam with a bit of jam,
but it's subtly sweet.
For Chinese people, if you say
a dessert is not very sweet,
that's actually a compliment.
Pineapple pie, also one of my favorites.
Mm. That is heavenly.
I think I'm going to finish this.
Now I need to chew for a very long time.
So, here we've got the strawberry sundae,
which is kind of melted already,
but I'm sure it would've been
amazing when it first arrived.
An affogato and a
matcha-flavored affogato,
and then here we've got the McFlurrys.
This is the strawberry McFlurry
with Oreo cookies.
Oh, my gosh, that is perhaps
the most sinful thing
that you could have.
Oh, but it's so good.
This is just the regular McFlurry,
and here is my all-time favorite,
mango-pomelo-sago-flavored McFlurry.
Hm. It's very different
with the ice cream.
You still got the mango in there,
and the pomelo, it's
very juicy, it's tender,
like little tiny pips in there
that kind of pop when you eat them.
Oh! Just perfect.
Mm. Brain freeze. Oh!
In the US, you can get yourself
a McFlurry with mini M&M's.
For some reason, mini M&M's
taste better than regular M&M's.
I love mini M&M's. Mm.
Hot caramel sundae.
It's classic. They don't
have this in China?
God, I mean, what's more
American than an apple pie?
Look at this thing. Let's
crack that bad boy open.
We got chocolate chip cookies.
Shakes. You can get three
different types of shakes
here at a US McDonald's. Chocolate.
Classic chocolate.
Strawberry, personal favorite.
That's so good.
Vanilla, the classic.
Our exclusive drinks
include the Fuze iced tea.
We've got the Minute Maid orange McFloat,
bubble tea, soy milk,
pure milk, Ceylon black tea,
which in China we would call red tea,
which just confuses you for fun.
I'm going to go back to here
because this is the
only thing I want to try
out of all of them.
That tastes like orange juice.
It's just plain old orange juice.
In the US, you can get
yourself a Dr Pepper,
a Fanta orange and an
Orange Lavaburst, lemonade.
You can also get frozen drinks.
You can get a frozen Fanta
blue raspberry or frozen Coke.
McDonald's also has smoothies.
A mango pineapple smoothie
and a strawberry smoothie.
Yeah, they make a decent
smoothie at McDonald's.
As you can see,
we have an absolute ton of
breakfast options here in China.
I think McDonald's has done
fantastic in this regard
because the Chinese treat
breakfast as a very special meal.
We have a very similar saying to,
"Eat breakfast like a king,
lunch like a prince,
dinner like a pauper."
So, starting with the
sausage McMuffin with egg.
Always a good way to start the day.
You can get this as a double as well.
Next we have the ham muffin.
It's just literally a piece of ham,
some lettuce, and two muffins,
so I guess this would
actually be a hamburger.
You can get this as a double as well.
Next we have the grilled chicken muffin.
This chicken's been
sitting around for a while.
Next we've got the
crispy chicken McMuffin.
So this is the breakfast version of the
"such a big chicken chop."
Breakfast in the US. We have
so many breakfast options,
starting down here, the sandwiches.
Egg McMuffin. Maybe the first
fast breakfast sandwich
to ever hit the market.
Sausage McMuffin. Sausage and cheese.
If you hadn't noticed,
this is all on what we
call an English muffin,
'cause they're from England.
There's also a bacon,
egg, and cheese McMuffin.
But the option that we have most for
are the scrambled-egg burgers.
Scrambled-egg grilled chicken burger.
The scrambled egg is
very luminously yellow.
Wow, look at that.
Very peppery.
They love their pepper here, don't they?
So, the scrambled-egg sausage burger.
You'll notice the buns are different now.
We're no longer on the muffins.
We're back to regular buns.
Oh, it's squeezing out, isn't it?
Scrambled-egg cheeseburger.
This is the brightest burger
I've ever seen in my life.
It's definitely very portable.
I think that's one thing that
McDonald's has done very well,
because Chinese breakfast
traditionally is not too portable
in the sense that you need to
sit down to a lot of meals,
like if you want to eat
wonton in the morning
or if you want to eat
some soups in the morning.
This you can just take and go.
And, of course, you can
get the scrambled-egg
German-flavor-sausage burger.
Oh, at least they give you two,
as opposed to just one tiny sausage.
Biscuits, biscuits, biscuits.
Sausage and egg biscuit.
So, the biscuits are the
same breakfast sandwiches
you get in English-muffin form,
but in this biscuit form,
the American biscuit,
this dry, crumbly, buttery biscuit,
there is a bacon, egg, and cheese one.
For some reason people in this country
seem to want just a biscuit and sausage
with no sauce, no nothing.
This is as dry as if
you'd go into a barbershop
and take a handful of hair clippings
and just shove them in your
mouth. This is that dry.
In the US we have something
called McGriddles,
and McGriddles are breakfast sandwiches
where they replace the
English muffin and/or biscuit
with pancakes.
So, first of all, they got the
McDonald's logo right there.
Too hilarious.
Somehow, through the miracle of science,
was able to inject syrup
into these pancakes.
Sensational.
You can get your McGriddles
in sausage, egg, and cheese
and then just sausage.
On to what I was going to
talk about, the congee.
Congee is a very traditional
breakfast item here in China.
It's basically just rice porridge,
and it's something that is
kind of like chicken
soup for Chinese people,
in the sense that if you fall ill,
you're going to be given one
of these, plain, with nothing.
This I think is with century egg,
but the century egg,
it tastes a little bit
like a blue-cheese version of egg,
in that it's kind of
like egg that's gone off,
but in a very nice way.
And this adds a nice
savoriness to the congee.
You can also get it with
pickles and bamboo shoots.
And if you're going to get congee,
then usually you need to pair it
with what they've called
an "Asian dough stick."
This is what we call a youtiao,
which is literally a stick of fried dough.
These are absolutely amazing
when paired with stuff like soy milk
and, of course, with congee.
You know, you need to eat these fresh.
Deep-fried, they are so incredibly crispy.
Oh, wow, well done, McDonald's.
Like, 10 hours later,
these are still crispy.
I'm very impressed but
also a little bit worried
because they should never be
this crispy after that long.
I wonder what they've put in here.
Last but not least, our
German sausages again.
It's not just sandwiches, you guys.
We also have something in the US,
the Big Breakfast, which
is totally in disarray.
This is like the advertising
for this breakfast.
I'm sorry?
The Big Breakfast with pancakes.
You can also get hotcakes, aka pancakes.
There's no way they're back
there, like, ladling the ...
right? There's no way they're doing that.
These have to be premade and
they just heat them up, right?
So, hotcakes and sausage.
Oh, and they both come with syrup,
so you know what we gotta do.
Oh-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho, yeah!
We also have a
morning wrap with ham.
The wrap itself is basically frozen solid.
We can exchange that with sausage,
which is also frozen.
It's almost like a piece of art now,
like you're supposed to look
at it instead of eating it.
Wow, frozen in time.
US McDonald's have
sausage breakfast burritos.
I mean, I can't even unfold,
I'm just, like, ripping it apart.
You got scrambled eggs, the sausage,
it comes with Mexican-style salsa.
Hey, McDonald's, it's actually pretty good
considering that this is, like,
probably the furthest
you can get from salsa
and still legally be
able to call it salsa.
If you're not trying to
completely destroy your insides
first thing in the morning,
you can get yourself
fruit and maple oatmeal.
Seems like your breakfast
is trying to escape
your body an hour later,
might actually be able to hold this down.
Et voilà, ze options from le bakery.
So, we have macarons.
Right now we have two different flavors,
chocolate and berries.
These actually look really legit.
Pat yourself on the back.
This is really good.
And these things are lamingtons.
I've never actually had lamingtons.
Apparently, they're basically
Australian sponge cakes
which are covered in coconut flakes,
and this is a lemon-flavored one.
Surprisingly addictive.
We have the McCafé bakery.
At the McCafé bakery, you
get, you know, sweet treats,
not necessarily for breakfast
but probably leaning more
towards breakfast time.
Ba-bam, blueberry muffin.
A cinnamon roll with
cream cheese frosting.
It looks like it's squishy.
It most certainly is not.
I mean, come on, who doesn't
love an apple fritter?
An apple fritter is a doughnut
that tastes like apple
and is shaped like it was
just squoze in someone's hand
for some strange reason.
These are our McCafé drink options,
starting with the extra-milky
latte with oat milk.
A latte is two-thirds milk,
and then you add oat milk in there,
I don't think we're going
to have much coffee.
Oh. Oh, wow, that is surprisingly good.
In China, oat milk has
really, really taken off
because a lot of people did
not grow up drinking milk.
A lot of Chinese people
are lactose intolerant.
And so oat milk is definitely
a very healthy alternative,
and that's why we have the
extra-strong chocolate with oat milk.
You can also get this without oat milk.
Extra-strong matcha milk.
Extra-strong matcha --
oh, we have so much matcha.
Extra-strong chocolate smoothie,
extra-strong milk and vanilla smoothie,
and the matcha milk with matcha jelly.
Matcha, matcha, oh, I'm going to --
We absolutely love matcha here
in China. I don't know why.
It tastes like grass and frozen grass.
Coffees and coffees and
coffees and coffees.
McDonald's has a assortment
of featured drinks,
espresso drinks, mochas, iced lattes.
Let's get all that on the screen.
See? All these things.
This is the cold brew. This is so strong.
I think each of you should
eventually take a sip.
You will not believe how
strong the cold brew is.
Oh, my God.
French vanilla latte.
This is the exact
opposite. This is so sweet.
Mocha. Who doesn't want hot chocolate
first thing in the morning?
Hilarious, people are buying that.
Ooh, this is the premium roast coffee.
I know I've been kind of dissing on it,
but their actual coffee, the
actual McDonald's coffee,
I think is very good.
They're a good contender in
the coffee game, I think,
in the fast-food coffee game.
Especially the horrible
PR nightmare they had
when they, like, destroyed
that lady's crotch
with their superhot coffee.
It is a comeback story, McDonald's.
Almost killing a woman
with second-degree burns
from boiling-hot coffee
to these nice little fun café drinks.
I would happily pour
this all over my crotch.
You can get the iced-coffee drinks.
Don't like this. This is the mocha.
McDonald's in China also
has a late-night menu.
They only have one item,
but this is worth it.
I got it last night. These
are marinated chicken bones.
They don't sound very appealing,
but the Chinese name
is wordplay on an idiom
which kind of means "the
highest level of artistry."
And when I opened up this box,
[gasps]
I literally heard angels going, "Aah!"
This is actually a street food
from someplace up in Northeast
China called Shenyang.
Chinese people love fiddly stuff,
and meat on the bone is
just that much more tasty.
Ah, still incredible, even cold.
You know, the box actually
says "marinated chicken bones."
"Be careful, it may contain bones."
And you're actually supposed
to spit the bones out,
but I'm having so much
fun eating this thing,
I actually eat the bones too.
It's spicy, it's sour, it's sweet.
Ah, and just absolutely divine.
I can see how people would be
inspired after eating this.
So, McDonald's came to China in 1990,
and then it opened in Beijing in '92.
Back then, that was the largest
McDonald's in the world.
They had 700 seats.
On opening day, they served 40,000 people.
And people didn't go there for the food.
It was a place to be seen.
Like, McDonald's was a window to the West.
It was a cosmopolitan place
to experience capitalism, in a way.
But over time it became
a trendy hangout spot
for city kids after school.
They'd go there to do their homework.
It still very much is middle class.
I remember actually when I came
to visit China 20 years ago,
my aunts greeted me at the
airport with bags of McDonald's,
and I was actually kind of offended
that they would bring junk food to meet me
as opposed to real Chinese food,
but for them McDonald's
was the best of the best.
It was all the prestige.
Hey, to me, McDonald's,
when it comes to fast food,
is No. 1 in the US, dare I say the world.
If you just want a good hot meal
where you know exactly what
it's going to taste like
and get it and go, McDonald's never fails.
Waiting in line, getting
it at the drive-through,
you get it lickety-split.
Now they leaned really big
into delivery since COVID,
and, man, McDonald's is
showing up right away,
and I love it. It's dangerous.
I can't remember the last time
I've eaten inside at a McDonald's.
So, I usually dine in at McDonald's,
but I find that in China
they focus more on delivery,
and they promise to get
everything delivered
within 30 minutes, which
they actually keep to,
and that's incredibly impressive.
Last night I ordered the chicken carcass.
It took 28 minutes.
Got a Big Mac earlier.
That was 10 minutes.
So they're very, very punctual.
They're also open for very long,
from 7 till 10 p.m.,
and there are many 24-hour branches,
so extremely convenient.
Now, McDonald's is an American brand,
so they have American
classics on the menu,
hamburgers, chicken sandwiches,
but they kind of
assimilated and made popular
the burger culture in this country.
It's hard to say, because I feel like
the American taste is McDonald's.
I think McDonald's has actually adapted
pretty well to Chinese tastes.
Besides the McSpicy burger and wings
and the grilled chicken sandwich,
which have all become bestsellers,
McDonald's actually
uses chicken thigh meat
instead of breast meat in
all of its chicken burgers,
except for the McChicken.
And I think that's because Chinese people
think chicken breast is dry,
and they've also got lots
of time-limited specials
when it comes to the desserts,
like the mantou burger,
which is kind of like a Chinese bun,
and even cilantro sundae.
McDonald's, everyone's
going after McDonald's.
Burger King's been going after McDonald's
since, what, the '60s?
Every burger chain
try to get some sort
of edge on McDonald's.
We're fancier, we got
different varieties of stuff.
McDonald's is No. 1,
here, now, and forever.
The McDonald's logo should be
on the American flag, dammit!
So, China is McDonald's
second-largest market
by store count, after the US.
In China, there are over
5,000 McDonald's locations,
but KFC has over 9,000.
They actually came here first,
so it's KFC, then McDonald's,
then a local brand called Dicos,
which does both fried chicken and burgers,
so they're really just
fighting an uphill battle.
In China, a Big Mac costs 25 yuan.
A Big Mac in the US costs $5.29.
Make it a Big Mac meal
with a medium fries and
medium Coke, and it's 36 yuan.
If you want to go large,
that's 4 yuan extra
for a grand total of 40 yuan.
If you make it a meal
with a medium fries and medium drink,
price goes up to $9.29.
Upgrade that to a large, and it's $10.79.
Our Big Mac large meal costs 86% more.
So our Big Mac meal is cheaper,
but at the same time
the average daily wage
of a cabby in Beijing is
about 200 yuan, give or take,
and so this would be 20% of their salary.
So it's still not really something
that you would eat on a regular
basis, but maybe splurge on.
Let's talk nutrition.
This is that very Big Mac, again.
In the US, it's 590 calories
and all this stuff.
In China, our Big Mac has 524 calories,
26 grams of fat, 45 grams of carbs,
27 grams of protein,
and 877 milligrams of sodium.
What if we did a combo?
Starting with the medium fries,
this adds 320 calories to the meal,
and all this stuff.
While a medium fries in
China contains 290 calories,
13 grams of total fat,
35.9 grams of carbs,
we're not sure if it contains any sugars,
4 grams of protein,
and 252 milligrams of sodium.
But you need something to drink.
Add in a medium Coke to that,
and this kicks your meal
up another 210 calories.
We'll do the same.
Here's everything in a
medium Coke in China.
148 calories. That leaves the grand total
for the China meal at 962 calories.
While in the US, the total
ends up looking like this.
1,120 calories and all this other stuff.
Get a load of that sodium, though.
Guh!
Tianran: From calorie
counts to portion sizes,
we wanted to find all the differences
between Domino's in China and in the US.
This is "Food Wars."
Here in China, Domino's
comes in three sizes:
the 7-inch small, which is
only available for two pizzas,
the fruit deluxe and the cocoa brownie,
hand-tossed only;
the 9-inch regular; and the 12-inch large.
In the US, our Domino's
pizzas come in four sizes:
small, 10-inch; medium, 12-inch;
large, 14-inch;
and the XL, 16 inches.
No, there's nothing on your screen.
The pizza is in fact that greasy.
We have three types of crust,
pan crust, hand-tossed,
and the thin crust,
and eight different crust
options, including stuffed crusts,
which are only available
outside of the US.
The UK has them. We have them.
Sweet-potato-stuffed crust.
You see that?
The orangey bit in there.
That's pretty good, actually.
It reminds me a little bit of a mooncake
in that it's sweet and savory.
Stuffed sausage crust.
Just a little sausage
peeking out of the hole.
Boletus crust. And
basically it's a mushroom.
It's a variety of mushroom,
of which there are many different species.
They're actually poisonous,
so you need to cook them properly.
If they're undercooked, they
will cause hallucinations.
The mushroom seller I met,
her husband actually
was poisoned four times,
and once he saw a bunch of
skulls either side of him.
Once he saw a mountain of gold.
One other time he just beats up a fridge,
and the last time he slept for three days.
It just tastes like wet mushroom.
Actually, we do have mushrooms
that make you hallucinate
in the US as well,
although you can't get them at Domino's.
Salted-egg-yolk-stuffed crust.
It's recommended that this is
paired with the chicken pizza,
so you basically have the
whole family in there.
That is delicious.
It tastes like a million
calories. Such a guilty pleasure.
Mm-hmm.
The meat-floss-stuffed crust.
It's not the most appetizing name, is it?
It looks a little bit like lint,
but it tastes like bacon cotton candy.
Usually it's made of pork,
but you can also get it as
beef or chicken or fish.
I don't think it quite works in crust
when crust is already so dry.
We also have something
called the double decker thin
and the double decker thick.
Correct me if I'm wrong.
I think this is actually the
double decadence from the UK.
I mean, it is pretty
much a pizza sandwich.
US Domino's, we have five
different dough varieties.
A better way of saying that is
five different crust options.
Dough varieties, yeah, same thing.
Anyway, first one down here
is a gluten-free crust,
and I want to note that it
only comes in the small,
because from Domino's perspective,
if you want gluten-free pizza,
you're eating it by yourself.
Next is the hand-tossed, kind
of the classic style, right?
Everyone's seen the hand-tossed.
To me, it's the default setting.
After that, this is the
crunchy thin, cut into squares.
That's a tavern cut, for
all you in the Midwest.
Another crust/dough variety is the pan.
This is a thick boy.
Only comes in a medium.
And, of course, the last
one is the Brooklyn style,
which you can only get in
the large or the extra large,
and it's thin and also has
these really big slices.
I can't tell. That's eight slices, right?
No, six slices, right?
So, it should be eight.
I don't know. Can someone in post
increase the contrast on that
to maybe make the lines
a little more obvious?
Our Domino's largest pizza
has a diameter of 12 inches,
or 30.5 centimeters,
and an area of
730.6 centimeters squared
and costs 88 yuan, or 12.81 USD.
Breaking that down, our pizza is 0.11 yuan
per square centimeter.
Take our large 14-inch, or
35.56-centimeter, pizza,
with an area of 993.1 square centimeters.
That's 0.15 cents per square centimeter,
or 0.96 yuan.
That means our US Domino's
pizza per square inch
is roughly 12.5% cheaper than in China.
Our Domino's categorizes their
pizzas into three groups,
indulgent, classic, and value.
Let's take a look at the indulgent first.
French-style liver mousse ham pizza.
I'm not even sure what a liver mousse is.
I assume it's meant to be foie gras.
It smells like foie gras.
Oh, but it is weird with pizza, man.
No, that should not be eaten with pizza.
That is super weird.
Why?
Mm, no.
Let's grab some New Zealand lamb.
It may be New Zealand lamb,
but they've used a lot of cumin
and basically turned
it into a lamb skewer.
Definitely miles better after that.
The sultan durian pizza.
That is a really healthy,
big piece of durian.
Abalone and scallop indulgent pizza.
I mean, just why?
Abalone is super expensive,
and it's popular in China
because its name sounds like
"to get explosively rich,"
so you'll often find
it served at weddings,
at Chinese New Year.
Ugh.
Let's clean our palate.
We'll get some Australian/New
Zealand wagyu beef.
I'd eat the beef by itself.
I'd remove everything else.
Crayfish and chicken.
I think they've gone full NOLA here,
because the chicken are
meant to be Orlean chicken,
and then we've got them craw daddies, too.
Chicken and crawdads?
I love New Orleans food,
so yeah, I would
definitely try that pizza.
South American rib eye steak.
The burdock prawn bacon indulgent pizza.
We've got peas, we've got prawns,
we've got some cherry tomatoes.
This is the Japanese-style-eel pizza,
and on the description, it actually says,
"May contain soft bones. Eat with care."
Oh, they're very tasty, though.
Here we have the Australian/South American
grain-fed diced beef, so
they either weren't sure
where the beef was sourced from
or if they run out of beef from Australia,
they go to South America.
And over here we have a
pineapple shrimp pizza.
You know, for those of you
who hate Hawaiian pizzas,
this must be so much more triggering.
No. I think it's actually
worse than a Hawaiian.
Also in the indulgent lineup
is our regular durian pizza.
This is actually a best seller.
It costs 9 yuan less than the sultan.
Oh, yeah. No, that's great.
Mm. Oh, that's delicious.
Here we have the
okonomiyaki surf and turf.
Look at that. That's
actually pretty decent.
It's even got the furikake intact.
Look at that. These
little superthin flakes.
Mm, that's decent.
Well done. Yeah, that's pretty good.
Very meaty, too.
Bacon, meat floss, potato pizza,
and it is absolutely
blanketed in meat floss
and a gigantic potato wedge.
It's a little bit like the Hawaiian pizza,
except instead of a juicy pineapple
you have sweet
bacon-flavored cotton candy.
Mm, not sure if like.
The Domino's US menu
obviously is not as robust
as China's Domino's menu,
but there are some specialty
pizzas you can get here
that you can't get there, including these.
First one here is the
Extravagan, two capital Z's, a.
This looks like a rebranding
of what would be called
a supreme pizza here. Right?
Now, if you hate vegetables, don't worry.
You can get the same pizza
but just MeatZZa version.
We got sausage, ham,
pepperoni, possibly hamburger.
This could have been just a
sausage and pepperoni pizza,
and it probably would've tasted
the same. I'm just saying.
Philly cheesesteak.
Philadelphia, let us know in the comments
how insulted you are that the
sandwich that bears your name
is now in pizza form. And
this thing looks terrifying.
Steak, cheese. Like that.
Onion and green pepper, oh, and mushrooms.
Yeah, I mean, it's not bad.
I don't know if I want a
whole thing of this, though.
I already had just one bite,
I'm like, yeah, I got it.
It's more the novelty of, yeah,
I guess that does taste
like a Philly cheesesteak,
but also, now I gotta
eat this whole pizza.
Hm.
A Cali chicken bacon ranch,
which I'm going to go ahead and assume is,
what do you think?
Chicken, bacon, some sort of ranch.
I don't know what makes it California.
That's not bad.
Buffalo chicken.
In China, they had all
these really interesting
flavor combinations that
I'm sure someone was just
really trying to capture the
breadth of Chinese tastes.
Here, everything is like,
this exists somewhere else.
We just did a pizza form.
Case in point, Buffalo chicken.
Hey, do you like wings?
Yeah.
Do you want it in pizza form?
No.
Too bad. Buffalo chicken.
Another one here, spinach and feta.
No.
Because I just bit into
a thing of feta cheese.
No.
Another specialty pizza we
have exclusive to the US
and not in China is a
Wisconsin six-cheese,
which, assuming from the name, has,
let me go ahead and guess, six cheeses?
And they put Wisconsin on there
because Wisconsin is the cheese state.
Shout-out to Wisconsin.
On to our classic offerings,
beginning with the
salted-egg-yolk-flavored chicken,
which, as you can see, was
very welcomed by the crew.
We're already missing two pieces.
The Chinese name for this is golden sands,
which is a specific way of
cooking the salted egg yolk
so that it becomes a sort of frothy paste
that can be used to coat various things.
It's a salty, sweet umaminess.
Teriyaki beef potato pizza.
Teriyaki beef, yes.
The pizza itself is already quite starchy.
It's all carbs, and then
a potato on top of that.
It's a staple and a staple.
Most of these pizzas are sweet.
Peking duck pizza.
I'm very conflicted about this.
I like that they're representing us,
but this looks very blasphemous to me.
That actually sounds amazing.
Nope, nope, nope, nope.
Blasphemous. No.
OK, never mind.
I'd still try it, though.
Here we've got the tuna seafood deluxe.
Not that big a fan of
seafood pizza, myself.
Truffle-flavored sauce,
mushroom, and chicken pizza.
Two types of mushrooms in that pizza,
but note that the truffle
is a flavored sauce,
so that's not included as one
of the types of mushrooms.
Ah, no.
Normal pizza, yes.
Chorizo pizza.
I don't know why there's
peas on all of the pizza,
but look, I'm gonna take it
for just regular meat toppings.
Yes, chorizo, get in here!
Tastes like Bolognese sauce,
but it's OK. I can dig it.
Especially after all of this
stuff, I'll take anything.
And now our value options,
beginning with the Texas barbecue.
Now, the description says it has
Texas-style meat.
I assume it's ham.
Again, it's sweet, but here
since it's a barbecue sauce,
maybe a honey glaze, I'm OK with that.
The lychee chicken pizza.
Don't know why it's paired up like that.
This is actually a pretty
meme-errific pizza.
The name is very punny,
and it references a
middle-aged Chinese influencer
who screams at the top of his lungs,
"Aoligei!"
Which kind of just
translates to, "Come on."
Many times people have said
that I kind of look like
that guy, and it's just,
I don't know what they're talking about.
There's no resemblance whatsoever.
Aoligei!
All I taste is the lychee.
The potato bacon pizza.
This is one of Domino's
all-time bestsellers,
and the name in Chinese
actually says "American style."
I don't know, is this what
you guys eat over in yonder?
Nope.
Here we go.
Here's a taste of America.
Mm-hmm. Land of the free.
Who am I to judge?
I don't know what kind of potato wedges
Americans like to put on their pizza.
Korean-style fried chicken,
also with sesame seeds, seaweed,
marinara sauce, and
what looks like onions.
Hey, that's a winner.
Winner, winner, chicken dinner.
Veggie deluxe. Not touching it.
Over here we have something special.
These are our two smallest
pizzas, the 7-inchers.
This is the fruit deluxe.
Peach, blueberry jam,
pineapple, coconut gel.
Mm!
You know what's best?
It's actually meant to be sweet.
If I've tried one dessert pizza,
I'm going to try the other one,
the cocoa-flavored-brownie pizza
with brownie cubes and cocoa powder.
It's actually not so bad.
It reminds me a little bit
of Nutella on buttered toast.
I can dig it.
Still here.
Man, that's a lot of pizza.
We at the US Domino's have sandwiches,
specifically these seven.
Most of them are just versions of pizza
that are also in sandwich form,
first one being the Buffalo chicken.
Let's get a look in there.
The chicken, cheese, and the sauce.
The chicken habanero.
I like a habanero thing
because it has the sweet and the spicy,
pineapple and jalapeños,
together in one bite.
This one, bleh, Mediterranean veggie.
Feta cheese and spinach.
That's in the Mediterranean area, I guess.
Banana peppers, which I don't
think exist outside of the US.
Oh, the Philly cheesesteak. Ugh.
It's double depressing because, I mean,
the Philly cheesesteak is a sandwich.
It has a specific way of being made.
This is not what a Philly cheesesteak
is supposed to look
like. Why do this? Right?
Over here we got the chicken bacon ranch.
Bro, they were generous with the ranch.
Look at that.
Lots of bacon and chicken and the cheese.
Nice.
An Italian sandwich. Mamma mia.
Salami, cheese, ham, and another salami.
And, of course, what is more Italian than
banana peppers?
And the chicken Parm
sandwich, chicken Parmesan,
which is, again, an incredibly popular,
already well-established sandwich
that Domino's for some reason
felt they needed to deconstruct
and then reconstruct in a different way.
I don't want any of these.
No sandwiches here in China,
but what we do have is rib eye steak.
Waiter!
Oh, whoa!
That's a big piece of steak.
Hm.
Let's talk pasta and rice.
We have both!
Here are our pasta options.
All come with spaghetti,
or you can pay one extra
yuan to upgrade to penne.
Spag Bol. Looks decent. Smells good.
Lot of Bolognese on the pasta.
Spaghetti basil.
I'm pretty sure that's just a carbonara.
Here we've got a seafood pasta
with scallop and squid roe.
Here we've got the rice options.
Chorizo baked rice.
You've got some chorizo,
you've got some pepperoni.
Truffle-flavored baked rice
with chicken and bacon.
Not gonna touch that.
Don't like my truffles.
And just a nice wholesome curry beef rice.
Curry sauce, beef, rice.
What could go wrong?
No rice dishes in the US, but
we do have our own pastas,
four specifically.
This is the fourth Domino's "Food Wars"
that I have been a part of.
I want to again state that I
think the pastas at Domino's
are an absolute abomination.
So if you're watching from outside the US
and you think this looks
weird, you are correct.
This pasta is so weird!
Italian sausage marinara.
I mean, I can't even break
through the skin of this thing.
Come on, man.
Chicken carbonara.
Ugh.
Oh, it hurts my soul.
Ugh! Pasta primavera.
Whatever primavera means, it ain't this.
And last, chicken Alfredo. Ugh.
Both countries have wings.
In China, you can only get
your wings in orders of four,
unless you go for the wings combo.
Now, here we have four exclusive flavors.
Cantonese roast.
Sweet in a fruity sort of sweetness,
and you've got that barbecue smell.
It tastes like Chinatown.
Next we have the Orleans flavor.
Oh, it's very spicy. Wow.
Oh. Oh, my gosh.
We also have the honey and
the barbecue-flavored wings,
and I believe in the US
you just have them combined
as a honey barbecue,
but here we get an extra flavor out of it.
I'm sure some of you might have noticed
our wings look a little bit different.
A wing is made up of three parts,
the drum, the flat, and the tip.
Usually it's removed because
it doesn't have much meat,
but here in China we love fiddly food.
Basically, here in China,
we love the tip so much
that we even have an
entire dish devoted to
just the tip.
One thing I do love on the menu, though,
is the Domino's wings.
In the US, you can get wing
orders in eight, 16, or 32.
We only have four exclusive flavors,
starting down here at the hot.
Then the honey barbecue,
sweet mango habanero,
and last, the garlic Parmesan.
On the presentation,
this is especially hm,
but they are very good.
I mean, I'd still get pizza over wings,
but if you're going to get wing sides,
Domino's wings, not bad.
We also have roast skewers.
Now, these are something that
are popular street foods.
Here we've got some chicken satay skewers.
We've got beef skewers.
These also come in the lamb
version, incredibly delicious,
and also
roast sausages.
I think these are usually
what kids like to eat.
I don't usually see adults eating these.
These would be sweet sausages,
but they're very filling.
China also has seafood options,
namely our golden shrimp,
which actually look a little bit orange,
pollock bites, and regular fish bites.
Our other sides include chicken rolls.
I believe it's smoked chicken,
mayo, and egg and peas.
Those peas. Peas make it
into every single menu item
here at Domino's.
Mini hot dogs wrapped
in a very cute blanket.
It's almost like it outgrew its blanket.
Healthy salad, star-shaped hash browns,
onion rings, and potato wedges.
Both countries have garlic bread,
but ours, we do it a little differently.
Ours is stuffed with
cheese and other stuff.
For instance, this one right here,
jalapeño and bacon.
Why this over pizza?
Another one we have here
is the spinach and feta.
We have twists. We have bites.
Starting over here, we've got
the Parmesan bread twists.
Looks like it's kind of doing this,
like please don't give me diarrhea.
[toilet flushing]
Garlic bread twists.
Do you want this taking
up space in your stomach?
I don't.
Just get more pizza.
I mentioned it before. We got dips.
What are dips?
From what I can tell, just big portions
of something to dip these breads in.
First one is, oh, my good Lord.
Going to go ahead and assume
this is the five-cheese.
Look at that, Yuelei.
Look at the oil on this.
Ugh.
You know what it tastes like?
Like pizza, but without the sauce.
And not to be outdone,
looks like the cheese one,
but this one, you guessed it, has
marinara sauce.
So if you got sick of having bread
with the sauce and cheese on it,
you can just get the
sauce and cheese baked
and then the bread baked separately
and just dip them!
Who wants this instead of pizza?
I don't understand, but all right.
We have square garlic
bread and garlic bread.
I actually don't know
what the difference is
besides the shape,
but they both come with
this honey mayo dip.
I actually thought this was mustard.
I think it's mustard, mayo, and honey.
I think the bread is just
an excuse to eat this dip,
because it is actually pretty good.
We also have soups.
You can get a nice bowl
of pumpkin cream bacon,
classic borscht, or
cream of mushroom soup.
Desserts.
Unfortunately, both China
and the US have lava cakes,
so it is not exclusive,
but we have a couple things
that you can't get in China,
specifically these cinnamon bread twists
and the Domino's marbled cookie brownie.
Come on, who doesn't like brownies?
And you can tell they put a
little cookie dough in there.
It's a cookie-brownie hybrid.
And we got this icing that
you would dip in here,
and I'm not going to do it.
I've decided I'm taking a stand
against all twisted bread.
Not happening, sorry.
Here in China, our
exclusive dessert options
are limited to durian pie.
I believe this is durian.
I had a sniff.
It's durian.
You can always tell if
something is durian.
Just put your nose to it.
Pineapple pie,
and we have one of two
Portuguese egg tarts.
Drinks. In the US, you can
get Sprite, Fanta orange,
Dasani water, and Dr Pepper.
This is emblic leafflower
and coconut jelly.
I had to do quite a bit of research
to figure out what an emblic is.
Apparently it's some kind of fruit
that actually has a lot
to do with Buddhism,
but it has great cooling
and cough-relieving properties,
so this is perfect for summer
when it's too hot outside.
Oh.
It's kind of nice, but
it also kind of tastes
like I'm drinking green
perfume, if that makes sense.
It's very, very floral.
This is coconut and musk melon.
Hm.
Oh, that's tasty.
It's a little bit too
rich, so nay to that.
And this,
this is carambola and olive.
It's such a weird combination, right?
So, a carambola is this thing.
It's a star fruit, but I've
never had it as a drink.
And together with Chinese olive? OK.
Learn something new every day.
Mm. Oh, that was a pleasant surprise.
There was actually some coconut
jelly at the bottom, too,
that was very inviting.
We also just have a regular
mango and passion fruit drink.
Oh, and bottled water.
Domino's entered China in 1997,
but for about two decades, they
pretty much just floundered
and nobody really took notice of them.
It was only really in recent years
that they've become very youthful
with all sorts of wacky
flavors, as you've seen,
and because it's not
as common as McDonald's
or KFC in China, a Domino's
opening in, for example,
a tier-two, tier-three
city is big news to locals,
and a lot of people actually
post about it on social media.
"Oh, look, a Domino's
has come to our town."
It's something to be proud of.
Domino's in the US,
I feel like it's been
Domino's versus Pizza Hut,
Pizza Hut versus Domino's
since I think the '80s.
Yes, there's other
nationwide pizza chains.
Papa Johns sucked up
a lot of the attention
online for a while.
There's Little Caesars,
there's a bunch of other ones,
but it really is Domino's and Pizza Hut
have been neck and neck.
I mean, they're kind of interchangeable.
Now people watching are
going to be like, "No,
one's better than the other."
Honestly, I don't think I
could taste the difference
if you put them side by
side, but with Domino's,
as far as the reputation, you always know
you're going to get a
good pizza, a hot pizza,
it's going to be decently
priced, which is nice.
Here in China, Domino's
main rivals are, of course,
Pizza Hut, who dominates the market
with a steady 5% market share.
Next in line is a local
brand called Champion Pizza,
with 5.6% of the market share.
And third comes Domino's,
at 5.3% of the market share.
Like in the States, Domino's
China has a guarantee
to deliver your pizza within 30 minutes.
Otherwise, they will give
you all sorts of discounts.
This really sets them apart
from other pizza players here in China,
because they use their own
proprietary delivery service,
whereas most restaurants
in China use a third party
akin to something like Uber Eats.
It's also something that's become
a bit of a double-edged
sword, because people
will actively try and game
their 30-minute delivery window
by switching off corridor
lights, removing door numbers,
and just generally trying to get
their delivery drivers lost,
and about half of all of Domino's
salary payments go towards
their delivery drivers,
which shows you how big of
a delivery force they have,
which is actually kind of quite nice.
Convenience, I mean, Domino's is probably
one of the most convenient pizza chains
in the United States.
You can get a Domino's pizza,
you can get it in the app,
it's easy to use, the
pizza's at your place
in probably 30 minutes,
depending where you live.
Some would say too convenient.
The Domino's in China doesn't disclose
their nutritional information,
but based on third-party
independent research,
we found that a large
hand-tossed pepperoni pizza
has 1,466.4 calories,
64 grams of protein,
66.4 grams of fat,
155.2 grams of carbs,
and 3,257.6 milligrams
of sodium.
Our large pepperoni is
370 calories per slice,
or 2,960 for the entire pie.
Also, 299% of your daily sodium.
Oy! That's a salty pie.
Domino's China's most
calorific pizza is this,
the large salted-egg-yolk-flavored
chicken pizza
with stuffed sausage crust.
Now, one slice is 230 calories,
and the full pizza is 1,841 calories.
Our Domino's pizza with the most calories
is the Cali chicken bacon ranch.
An extra-large slice is 560 calories,
and the full pie, 3,360 calories.
Two ingredients you won't
find in Domino's in China
are potassium bromate and ractopamine.
Both have been banned for use in China.
Potassium bromate is used
as a dough conditioner,
and it's classified as
a category 2B carcinogen
by the International Agency
for Research on Cancer.
Ractopamine is FDA-approved,
and it promotes muscle-mass development,
limits fat deposition, and
reduces feed consumption.
Although it is considered
safe for human consumption,
China requires all meats
sold to be free of the drug
and never fed the product to begin with.
There is no direct link
stating ractopamine
is specifically used in
the meat at Domino's,
but on their stewardship
page under "Animal Care,"
they state, quote, "It's
important to highlight
that Domino's does not
own, raise, transport
or process the animals
used for our products.
Domino's purchases pork,
beef and poultry ingredients
from suppliers who obtain their products
from farmers and ranchers
who raise and care
for their animals in
compliance with local,
state and federal guidelines,
industry best practices
and the support of farm
and animal veterinarians."
That is a very long legalese
way of Domino's saying,
"Hey, we don't farm the meat.
We buy them from other people,
and they're saying they're
doing it the right way,
so we don't know."
Tianran: From exclusive
items to portion sizes,
we wanted to find out all the differences
between KFC in China and the US.
This is "Food Wars."
Here in China, we can get
KFC in three portion sizes:
one piece, two pieces, and six pieces.
In the US, KFC chicken comes
in seven portion sizes.
These first four are one-piece à la carte;
two-piece with a combo,
that's a side, a biscuit, and a drink;
three-piece, also with a combo;
and the four-piece, also with the combo.
And, of course, we have buckets.
We have three main core buckets.
The snack bucket,
which contains five pieces
of chicken and six wings;
the family bucket,
which gets you an extra corn on the cob,
some mashed potato, and three drinks;
and the super family bucket,
where you get dessert and mashed potato,
more of both on top of that as well.
And then we have buckets, where
you can get an eight-piece,
a 12-piece, or the 16-piece.
Now, if we're going strictly
on just chicken and not wings,
the US's largest is
166-point-repeating-6% bigger
than China's largest chicken portion size.
Next we have fries.
Now, here in China, we
get them in three sizes:
small, medium, and large.
We got two fry sizes in the US:
the individual and the large.
Let's weigh the large
fries in both countries.
[Joe laughs]
I never grow tired of that.
Here in China, our drinks
come in three sizes:
small, medium, and large.
American drinks come
in the following sizes:
regular, 20 ounces; and large, 30 ounces.
But that's not all.
You can also get a half-gallon container.
Guzh!
The Jesus piece of any
beverage of your choosing.
Damn!
Hope you're sharing that, Joe.
Here's everything you'll
find in a KFC China
that you won't find in the US.
We have a lot to get through.
Here's everything you'll
find at a KFC in the US
you won't find in China.
One exclusive that we have here in China
that you cannot find in the US are wings.
[record scratch]
That's right.
It's tough times for the US economy
in just about every sector.
Earlier this year,
KFC laid off several favorite
menu items, including wings,
Nashville-hot-sauced
anything, strawberry lemonade,
chocolate chip cookies, and
pretty much popcorn chicken.
They still exist in the famous
bowls but not on their own.
We still got them here,
and they're available in two styles:
the crispy spicy wings and
the New Orleans grilled wings.
Now, you might be wondering,
what are New Orleans wings?
Apparently KFC might
have invented the flavor,
and it's kind of like
how General Tso's chicken
is not actually from China.
New Orleans chicken is
kind of just a misnomer.
It's a honey-baked spicy wing with a,
I think a Cajun mix.
US chicken styles.
One chicken style you
can get here in the US
you can't get in China is
this: the extra crispy.
It's exactly what it sounds.
They fry it, like, twice
or with more breading, I don't know,
but it gives that extra-crispy crunch.
Volume up.
[chicken crunching]
In some parts of the country,
you can get Kentucky grilled.
Grilled chicken, not fried.
I mean, fried's in the title,
so I don't know what you're
doing getting grilled chicken
at KFC.
And for sandwiches, we
have a spicy option.
I just wanted to talk a little bit
about our chicken recipes here.
So, this is the original recipe,
but we also have an additional recipe
called the golden crispy chicken.
Now, you can tell that there's
quite a bit of a difference.
It is significantly more "golden"
in that I guess it is
lighter-yellow-colored
than the original.
But there's also a very healthy sprinkling
of chili powder on top,
and the batter is a lot
harder and crunchier.
I guess it's probably more
of a localized version of the chicken.
That looks delicious.
That's like extra crispy and spicy?
Yeah, I definitely want to try that.
Here we have our exclusive
burgers and roll.
We'll get to that later.
First off, I just want
to draw your attention
to the rattan-pepper-flavor
spa chicken burger.
I had a really tough
time trying to figure out
what spa meant.
And I found actually on
one advertising poster
in fine print that spa was not an acronym.
It just meant that the
chicken is juicy and tender
because this is made of chicken breast
instead of chicken thigh,
which you'll remember from another episode
is the norm here in China
because Chinese people think
that chicken thigh is juicy and tender,
whereas breast is really dry
and it's basically chalky.
So I guess the "spa" is an
attempt to get rid of that stigma
by saying, "Ah, look,
it's so soft and tender,
like the chicken's just
come out of a massage
or a spa treatment."
If you haven't had hot pot or
had Sichuan flavors before,
this might be a really big turnoff
because the taste of the
rattan pepper is so strong.
The chicken is all right.
You know, it's tender.
I can't say it's just come out of a spa.
The spicy chicken sandwich.
Looks basically the same.
Well, for one, it's not spicy.
And second, it's actually not as tasty
as the spa chicken.
I do actually — no, you know
what, I take it all back.
I do actually feel that the spa chicken
is a little bit more tender.
This one does feel drier.
The crispy chicken sandwich.
It's pretty much the
same as everything else.
I think they're really just
adding different condiments,
but the gist of it is always
lettuce, the mayo, and chicken.
That's it. And the bun, of course.
And the New Orleans chicken burger.
Of course, they're going to
put this in a burger as well
if they've gone and invented
an entire flavor category.
That's actually not bad.
And we have one more chicken option,
the old Beijing chicken roll,
or, as listed on their website,
the dragon twister.
So, they called it "old Beijing style,"
and I now understand
that "old Beijing" means
that you're going to chuck
some cucumber in there.
There's probably leek in there as well.
There's going to be tianmian sauce.
Let's give the dragon a taste.
It just tastes sweet.
There is a crunch from the cucumbers,
but the cucumber's kind of gone a bit ...
it's kind of gone a bit sad as well.
Now we've got the beef burger options.
This is the classic
American-style beef burger.
Imagine this being, like,
the introductory course
to American flavors for
someone who's never left China.
They're going to be
sorely disappointed. Ugh.
You can also get double
beef burgers at KFC
in your classic American style.
Ugh, no, thank you.
Or the smoked pepper flavor.
If you want a burger, go to
McDonald's, go to Burger King.
There's also a fish burger,
the deep-sea cod burger,
which you can get as a double as well.
I do have my hopes up for this one.
Not very high, mind you,
but I do have some hope for this one.
This is the bacon wagyu beef burger.
It's a premium burger,
as you can tell because
it comes in its own box,
which prevents it from becoming
squished into sandwiches
like these guys.
No.
I don't care if it really is wagyu or not.
In fact, it actually tastes a little bit
like the consistency of Spam.
You can get that as a double or a triple,
but just skip it in my opinion.
We have one exclusive sandwich to the US.
It's this: the Chicken Little,
which I guess is a
bite-size chicken sandwich.
A little tender in here also.
Hey, KFC, if I had one note,
maybe relax on the mayo on this.
Are you kidding me? Look at this.
The sauce, whatever this is, like,
bro, it is dripping.
Pickles, not a fan.
Get out of here.
Why this over the chicken
sandwich, I have no idea.
I mean, unless you have a kid
or a picky eater, skip these.
We've also got other chicken options,
beginning with our Hong Kong-style
crispy big chicken thigh.
If you've watched our other episodes,
you'll know that Hong Kong
style usually is used to denote
a sort of sweet
honey-roasted flavor profile.
Would've been oven-baked.
Look at this glaze.
That's beautiful.
Mm.
It's sweet without being cloying.
It's savory.
It's incredibly meaty.
There's also the secret
recipe whole chicken.
Look at that! An entire chicken!
See, it's about the size of my face,
and I've got a pretty long face.
You've done well.
You've done well, Colonel.
Mm. I forgive you for the burgers.
Heck yeah, dude. I totally
want one of those, man.
Just bite right into that big leg
like in medieval times.
This here is the
hot and spicy chicken with bone,
and apparently it's scapular meat,
so your collarbone.
I've never had collarbone chicken meat,
so this is definitely a first for me.
It tastes a little bit
like a chicken nugget
but with a bone inside.
And we've also got popcorn
chicken and nuggets.
You might be wondering what these are.
KFC is trying to squeeze
in on the pizza business.
This is KFC's K pizza.
This is a chicken and mushroom K pizza.
Look at that.
Ultrathin crust.
That's actually pretty good.
I think I actually like this
more than Domino's pizzas.
And this one is very special.
This is the K pizza dapanji flavor.
So, dapanji means "big plate of chicken."
It's a Xinjiang dish which
is usually a chicken stew,
comes on a giant dish, with
potatoes and bell peppers,
and you also get some
hand-pulled noodles thrown in.
In fact, the origin story
of the big plate of chicken,
supposedly was either invented
by a Sichuanese or a Hunanese immigrant
who was serving these
dishes up to truckers.
And they're very hearty.
They're super tasty.
You always eat them in a group,
but I'm just going to pig out
and eat one by myself on a pizza.
Mm.
KFC, this is legit good.
Announcement!
KFC has recently added
nuggets back onto the menu,
so they're technically
not an exclusive anymore,
but I'll show them off here.
You can get them in eight and 12 pieces.
Here's the nugget eight pieces.
Get in there, Yuelei. Nugget vision.
Now, remember before when I said
they didn't have popcorn chicken anymore?
I mean, this is pretty ... right?
It's a little bit bigger
than popcorn chicken.
When I said nuggets, you
were probably thinking
what I was thinking,
like McNuggets, right?
Like, nuggets.
So this being a nugget is very strange.
Really good, though.
We also have chicken tenders.
They come in orders of eight, 12, and 16.
The crispiness on this. I have to.
[chicken crunching]
Mm!
Now, to complement your chicken,
we have a plethora of sauces
and condiments to offer,
namely, sweet vinegar and sweet chili,
which we couldn't find today,
and the Sichuan pepper spicy chili powder.
You can't eat these dry.
You can get a bunch of exclusive sauces,
and you know what that means.
Sauce talk.
Starting off, the Buffalo ranch.
Thank you, nuggets. Let's go.
Yeah! The KFC sauce, really good.
Barbecue sauce, honey barbecue, excuse me.
Eh.
Classic ranch.
I don't know what the ranch
situation out there in China is,
but here, we're doing
all right with ranch.
The ranch situation in America, solid.
We also have a honey mustard
sauce, a honey sauce,
and a hot sauce.
All three today, they did not have.
Here in China, KFC has something
called the DIY kitchen.
And they also have stuff
from third-party vendors.
Without further ado, let's dig in.
First off, we have the chicken nuggets
and the hot and spicy chicken with bone.
If I was hungry and I wanted
KFC, I'm going to order KFC.
I'm not going to go and cook it myself.
Isn't that the whole point
of takeout? Of fast food?
It's cooked for you.
If you're so inclined,
you can also make KFC's
famous egg tarts at home.
KFC's also offering
secret-recipe chicken fillets
from a third-party vendor.
The whole-cut sirloin steak,
also from a third party.
KFC also selling you pasta now.
They come in mushroom and
black pepper, carbonara,
and spag Bol.
Actually, oh, this is the spag Bol.
You've got your Bolognese.
You've got various condiments.
Yeah, no to KFC pasta.
No to KFC pasta.
No to their burgers.
Chicken is your lane.
Stay in that lane.
They've also got rice.
They come in four flavors.
The original-flavor chicken
Japanese-style fried rice.
What's Japanese about it?
I can't tell.
And this one is the baked rice.
This one is the French-style
roast chicken cheese
baked rice.
And probably the most understandable
of the offerings in the
DIY kitchen, the ice cream.
So KFC have partnered up with Oatly.
As you can tell, Oatly is
just everywhere in China.
It's so big.
KFC also has this.
It's called the Modern ice cream,
although here in China
we call it the "Madier."
And it's got a really interesting history.
This originates from a
city in northeast China
called Harbin, where they hold
the Ice and Snow Festival,
if you know about that.
And, basically, modern
Harbin was more or less
built by the Russians.
The "Modern" gets its name from a hotel
that was built by a Russian,
which also had a bakery and
sold yogurt and ice cream.
So this has become an institution,
especially if you go
to Harbin in the winter
for the Snow and Ice festival,
when it's, like, minus 20.
People are still queuing up on the street
to get yourself one of these Popsicles.
It's been a while.
Let's see if the ice cream
is still good to eat.
It does feel a little bit soft.
Oh, it's like Frosty the
Snowman once summer's set in.
You can just have a peek.
I'll be able to drink it soon.
Mm. Salvageable.
What still is going strong on the menu
is the pot pie.
Man, this thing is hot. Aye!
I don't want to disrespect
any of the pot-pie-heads watching,
but I've never seen anyone order this.
I've never seen anyone eat this.
This thing is gigantic.
You can't get this as a side.
So someone in this country,
assuming lots of people are walking into
Kentucky Fried Chicken
and getting a pot pie,
I don't know why you're doing this.
Pot pie is perfectly fine.
I feel like this could
totally go on the menu.
If you want to fight me in
the comments, go for it.
But I've never met a person
who gets this and eats it.
And this is kind of my job.
We'll do a taste test later.
As for now, moving on. The famous bowl.
I don't think this exists
outside of America,
so let me go ahead and explain it.
It basically is every
side plus popcorn chicken,
or in this case nuggets, in one thing.
Mashed potatoes, gravy, cheese, corn,
and, yeah, bits of chicken.
Look, it's not that I don't
like all these things,
but together in one dish is kind of eh.
So what you're really
doing is getting a side
of mashed potatoes and gravy
and sprinkling some cheese,
corn, and chicken on it.
I don't know if people were
complaining on the internet.
The famous bowl is so good,
now they have the mac 'n' cheese bowl,
which is mac 'n' cheese
with chicken on it.
And these are the nuggets.
Remember I said before,
the popcorn chicken is still in this?
I mean, isn't this popcorn chicken?
Are these too big to be popcorn chickens?
Is this nuggets that have
replaced the popcorn chicken?
I want answers.
The nuggets are fine, and
the mac 'n' cheese too,
but together they don't add anything.
The only thing it's doing is being like,
"Why get it in two containers?
Just get it in one."
Speaking of mac 'n' cheese,
exclusive sides in the US,
you can get your mac 'n' cheese
without chunks of chicken in it.
Just regular mac 'n' cheese.
Our biscuits.
Oh, so dry.
Coleslaw.
China, you don't want this.
I mean, how do you even explain coleslaw?
Shredded lettuce. Shredded
cabbage, excuse me.
I don't even know what it is.
With, what, mayo and carrots?
And corn.
Like McDonald's, KFC also has
a late-night street-food menu.
But unlike McDonald's,
which only has one item,
the chicken carcass, KFC has four
and two different types
of chicken carcass.
I feel like the KFC version
is maybe a bit bonier.
So, this is probably the
Sichuan version then.
Let's take one of these fellas out.
I think preferable to the original.
This is pretty interesting.
This actually looks like
original-recipe chicken.
This, in fact, is called the
aoao big chicken carcass.
Aoao is onomatopoeic,
and it's from the
northeastern region of China.
Basically it's slang for "howling."
You know, that is
gigantic, and you're just,
you're dying to eat it.
So, Joe, if you come to China
and you want to order this,
you know what you gotta do.
You just go up to the counter and be like,
I want that [howls] chicken.
Got it.
And then they'll know
exactly what you want.
You can also get fried chicken feet,
but we've done one better and gotten
the fried chicken feet
and fragrant bones box.
This is the chicken feet, obviously.
There's also chicken neck,
there's chicken wing tip,
scapular meat.
So all of the fiddly parts of the chicken
in one convenient box
for you to nibble on.
These are all of our
exclusive breakfast options.
OK, so first off,
I just want to draw
your attention to this.
KFC has xiao long bao.
This is incredible because this is
a super-popular breakfast item.
If you wake up early,
you'll see lots of sellers
with bamboo steamers
about as tall as you are
filled with these sorts of little bao.
The KFC xiao long bao.
Oh, that's even better than my
neighborhood breakfast place.
Color me impressed.
I'm very, very, very smitten with this.
Plus they also provided a pack of vinegar,
because you can't eat bao without vinegar.
Next we have the congees.
In terms of flavors,
we've got the century egg
and pork, a staple congee.
This would be sour pickle and chicken.
And over here we've got
the chicken and egg.
This is the century egg and pork.
In goes — I don't
actually like century egg.
It's stanky,
but not as stanky as the
authentic century egg.
And the youtiao,
the crispy Chinese
cruller, or dough stick.
I mean, there are so many
different names for this thing,
but this is the heart of
every Chinese breakfast.
This goes well with soy milk.
You can dip it in soy milk,
you can dip it in congee.
It's like a churro but not sweet.
A bit chewy.
These things are always
best right out the wok.
Continuing on with our Chinese breakfasts,
this is just super cute.
This is something that's called a tea egg.
You get these in one or four.
And you're eating a tea egg,
you gotta have some youtiao.
And if you're having youtiao,
you gotta have some congee.
Mm-hmm.
That's the trifecta.
It's the holy trinity
of Chinese breakfasts.
We have the crispy chicken spring rolls,
although they've lost a bit of spring.
What is --
I feel like one of those
sausage-finger people
from "Everything Everywhere All at Once."
I didn't realize we were in the
floppy-crispy-spring-roll universe.
There's also a
chicken chop and egg Chinese-style roll,
although really this is more of a wrap.
And what do we have in here?
We've got chicken breast.
It looks like cucumber, leek.
This is what's known as a báo cuì,
which literally translates
to "thin and crispy"
and is meant to be thin and crispy,
but it's more like thin
and flaccid right now.
I think this is tianmian sauce,
which is a sweet bean paste.
I have to say this.
The Chinese breakfast
at KFC is next level.
I want all of that.
Are you kidding me?
All of that looks incredible.
Next, let's talk about the
non-Chinese breakfasts.
So, we've got our panini
offering right here.
We're going to begin with the
cheese and sausage panini.
Just your regular — I think
it's actually ciabatta bread.
Now we've got the
cheese, sausage, and egg.
The cheese and chicken panini.
The cheese and thick omelet panini.
Now, this is interesting
because this is a rolled omelet.
I think in Japan they
would call it a tamagoyaki.
Here we've got the chicken chop
thick-rolled-omelet double panini.
These three are special.
We got them just for you.
They are new offerings on the KFC menu.
In fact, KFC has been really
good at updating its menu.
Pretty much every month they're
going to have new stuff.
This is their soufflé lineup.
The cheese and egg soufflé panini.
It's basically the same eggy thing,
but it looks like it's
worked out more in the gym.
It's got a better pump.
Next we've got the chicken
chop and egg soufflé panini.
I just want to do a
side-by-side comparison.
Is it not the same thing?
And I saved the fanciest
of them all for last.
This is the beef fillet egg soufflé.
Oh, look at that.
They even made it rhyme.
OK, comes in its very own special box.
OK, so we've got the fluffy soufflé,
and then there's mashed potato
in my panini
and the beef fillet.
Now we have le French again. Le Français.
That was really bad.
I'm pretty bad at the
French accent. Sorry.
We have the smoked chicken
French-style croissant bread.
It's basically a Croissan'wich.
It's a square croissant with sesame seeds.
And le bacon and egg
French-style croissant bread.
The bacon and egg
French-style croissant bread,
if my accent was terrible.
Not as impressive with the paninis.
We've kind of got those here.
And, of course,
if you can't get enough of
the Western-style breakfast,
you can also get single add-on items
such as an egg, sunny-side up.
You can also get a nice juicy sausage.
Hash browns.
Always a must.
This is the egg and vegetable soup.
Here we've got the Hong Kong-style
big crispy chicken thigh rice.
This section beneath it is just
literally filled with rice.
And this is the spicy meat
sauce grilled chicken rice.
Here are two additional
non-chicken sides that we have.
Corn and wavy fries.
I get a whole chocolate cake.
KFC in the US.
I don't know why they
don't sell it by slices.
Guess it's for the whole
family or whatever.
What can I say about chocolate cake?
It's chocolate. It's got
frosting on it. It's very good.
I'm not going to bite into it.
We're going to donate it, so
I don't want to screw it up.
Trust me, it's good.
These are our exclusive desserts.
Let's begin with KFC's bestseller,
the Portuguese-style egg tarts,
or just the egg tarts for short.
And if you can't eat two whole egg tarts,
then you can go for the baby egg tarts.
Oh, look how cute they are! They're tiny.
KFC offers a Basque cheesecake,
and this is the red bean pie.
That's delicious.
KFC offers an original ice cream cone,
but because we got it delivered,
that's the cone, and
this is the ice cream.
Ah!
OK, I guess that's how I'm
supposed to take it out.
I'm just going to drink
the ice cream. Here we go.
This is a first.
Oh! Oh! Oh! OK.
OK, all right.
We're going to put it back.
Sundaes, we've got four of them.
Strawberry. Brown sugar and bubble sauce.
I assume bubble as in bubble tea.
This here is the mango
grapefruit sundae.
New on the menu, the North
American blueberry sauce.
Here, we've also got
supersoft-mochi sundaes.
This is the strawberry flavor,
and this is the one that I guess
is basically the milk-tea version,
but with mochi balls on top.
Following on in the footsteps
of the mochi sundae,
there's also supersoft
KFC mochi ice cream,
which comes in four flavors.
This one is strawberry.
Ah, no, this one's strawberry Oreo.
You can also get regular strawberry, Oreo,
and taro flavor.
That's actually pretty tasty.
Drinks. We got a bunch
of them here in the US,
starting down here.
Something that is new to America,
a lemon-lime beverage called Starry.
Sierra Mist is out. Starry's in. And ...
tastes almost exactly like 7Up.
You can also get Mountain Dew.
Oh, yeah.
A personal favorite:
Mountain Dew Sweet Lightning.
I think you can only get it at KFC.
It's, like, peach Mountain Dew.
I know it's not good for
me, but man, it's so good.
This is supposed to be a lemonade but
is in fact more Sweet
Lightning. Not complaining,
but you can also get
the Colonel's lemonade.
And last but not least, sweet tea.
Oh, yeah.
The sweet tea actually is good.
Love all these beverages.
These are all of our exclusive drinks.
Let's begin over here with
the most Chinese of them all.
Soy milk.
We have Budweiser.
The nine-fruits orange juice.
Then you've got your milk tea
with a very cute Colonel Sanders,
and a bubble tea, which is just as cute
and has the little tapioca
pearls at the bottom too.
Over here, the three-lemon tea,
consisting of lemon, lime, and orange.
It's basically just lemon juice.
Yeah, I can see why
it's called three lemon.
The heartwarming
three black goji oat drink.
Oh, if you can see the little
bits of red stuff floating in there,
it's got actual goji berries.
It makes me feel like a
middle-aged Chinese auntie
with curlers in my hair.
But in the best way possible.
I feel, I don't know,
I feel like I'm wearing PJs.
I think was the snow-top coffee,
which is basically an iced latte
with a dollop of ice cream.
And this also would've looked different
when it first arrived.
This is called the cute bubble milk.
Basically it's just straight-up milk
with a layer of milk foam,
and it would've had a smiley
face dusted in cocoa powder.
Oh, and I forgot to mention,
there's also a hot lemon drink
that we weren't able to get.
These are the K coffees.
K coffees come in hot or cold varieties.
You can get Americano,
your standard latte,
your oat-milk latte,
your rich-milk latte, your coconut latte.
Then you can also get the vanilla latte,
a hazelnut latte, sea salt
and macadamia nut latte,
and there's also your regular cappuccino
and caramel macchiatos.
Let's talk cultural perceptions.
In terms of prestige,
KFC really is the OG.
They opened in 1987, before Macky D's,
and back then they would've also been seen
as sort of a window to the West,
this fancy cosmopolitan place to be seen.
But over time,
they've really become quite entrenched
here in China,
and they're now seen as
a foreign fast-food brand
that I would say has a lot
of Chinese characteristics.
For example, the congee, the
breakfast menu, et cetera.
KFC's rep in this country, they're No. 1.
They're No. 1 with fast-food chicken.
We got Popeyes, we got,
I guess you'd want to put Chick-fil-A,
but that's more sandwiches.
As far as fast chicken-on-the-bone places,
Wingstop is wings, and Popeyes, and KFC.
Reputation is pretty much,
like, you're going to get
a decent piece of chicken
and a lot of sides.
In terms of convenience,
KFC has its own delivery service,
but it also uses third-party
suppliers like everybody else.
But unlike in the US,
where KFC is very much takeout-focused,
here in China, they're more
about the dine-in experience,
especially with the extended family.
KFC is incredibly convenient, reliable.
I wouldn't hang out at one or dine there.
I would take it to go.
One thing I should say about KFC,
as much as they work on
having quality control,
you could tell if a KFC is good or bad
by how dark the chicken
is when it comes out.
Like, the one that we did today,
I don't think they changed
the oil in a while.
The chicken was looking a
little darker than it should.
So that's kind of a
thing you gotta consider.
Convenience, usually the
service is pretty quick.
But it's April 27th,
so if somebody watching
this happened to get KFC
from Uber or DoorDash on
April 27th around 11:30
and your meal took longer
than you wanted, my fault.
Our big order pretty much
backed everything up.
Anyway, so it's usually
convenient when you don't live
in a neighborhood where
they shoot a "Food Wars."
So, in terms of adaptability,
KFC, as we mentioned before,
was the first to offer
congee and Chinese cruller,
soy milk on their breakfast menus.
Also, unlike McDonald's,
which kind of played up its
foreignness a little bit,
KFC when they came to the China market
had high-level managers who
actually spoke the language,
and so they adapted very quickly.
For example, there are lots
of regional differences
in terms of how much spicy people can eat.
Like, people over in
Shanghai were complaining
that the spicy chicken was too spicy,
but people over in Hunan in Central China
were complaining that
it wasn't spicy enough.
So they were very quick to react.
I think KFC, Kentucky
Fried Chicken, Kentucky,
Kentucky's in the United States,
so pretty much is local country tastes.
Yeah, they do the Nashville hot thing,
they occasionally bring
sauces in and out, but.
Rivals, KFC basically has none.
I mean, it's numero uno.
Over 9,000 stores.
Double the market share of McDonald's.
Way, way, way far ahead in the distance.
Unless they sit on their laurels,
they're probably going to be
cruising at No. 1 for a while.
KFC versus Popeyes,
I would say KFC has in America
at least four times as many locations.
Yeah, I think Popeyes tastes better, but,
I mean, as far as business is concerned,
KFC's not sweating it.
In China, this spicy chicken burger
is 19.5 yuan, or 2.83 US dollars.
A US spicy chicken sandwich is $6.99,
or 48.10 yuan.
That is a 147% price increase.
Make it a meal. Add a medium
fries and a medium Pepsi,
and the cost goes up to 42 yuan, or $6.10.
Still less than the cost
of a sandwich in the US.
Our US combo with tax is $13.75,
or 94.61 yuan.
That is a 125.4% increase
compared to China.
Our most expensive single menu item
is the fried-chicken
bucket and Budweiser meal,
which is 146 yuan, or $21,
and it gets you eight spicy wings,
eight New Orleans wings,
and four Budweisers.
I mean, I don't know where
the other three went.
Honestly, they must have just gotten lost
on the road or something.
In the US, we have two
menu items costing $49.99,
or 343.97 yuan.
That's either the 16-piece chicken meal
or the 16-piece tenders meal.
Both come with four large
sides and eight biscuits.
Unfortunately, KFC doesn't
share its nutrition data
with the public.
But what we do know is
that in 2020, Yum China,
which owns KFC and
Pizza Hut here in China,
partnered with the Chinese
Nutrition Society to research
and apply best nutritional
practices for the brand.
KFC in the US does have
nutrition info available.
Here are a few stats. All right.
If you get the Kentucky
grilled chicken drumstick,
it's 80 calories.
Crisp it up a little bit
with the original recipe
or the spicy,
now it's 130 calories.
Want to make it extra crispy,
like this one in my stomach?
Now you've increased the calories to 170.
That's 112.5% more calories
than the Kentucky grilled.
Get real, though. It's
Kentucky Fried Chicken.
If you want grilled chicken,
go dust off your George Foreman.
Speaking of calories, what
menu items have the most?
If you're going with the chicken,
the extra crispy, a
breast is 530 calories.
Sandwich, the recently
discontinued Double Down
has 950 calories.
For reference, a Big Mac has 550.
And for sides, the fries
are the top of the list.
An individual has 320 calories.
And then the family size,
which, let's be honest,
it's for one person,
has 840 calories.
I have been informed
that my fellow producer Yuelei Song
said that their favorite
thing on the KFC menu
is in fact the pot pie.
Would've been nice if you said something
while was going off about it.
Oh, God. There's peas in it?
What else is in here? What is this?
Tianran: From calorie
counts to portion sizes,
we wanted to find out all the differences
between Lay's in the US and in China.
This is "Food Wars."
In China, Lay's chips come in 14,
that's right, 14 sizes.
Coming in at our smallest
chip bag, 12 grams,
23, 40, there's a 45 but
we couldn't get that,
60, 65, 70,
75 grams, 80, 90,
104, 116, 135,
and 220 grams
for our largest chip packet.
In the US, Lay's come in six sizes.
There's only four. Let me explain.
Down here, the smallest bag
is the multipack 28-gram
bag, the vending-machine bag.
Move one up to a 2.625 ounce,
or 74.4 grams. So specific.
Then, in the middle,
which I couldn't find,
is the 2.75-ounce, or 78-gram, bag.
In the middle here, the classic, I mean,
this is the one you see everywhere.
The 8-ounce, or 226-gram, bag.
In the middle here,
missing, is the family size.
Too tragic for the American
family. They don't get to see
the 10.5-ounce, or 297.6-gram, bag.
But of course, the size
that we always have,
old reliable, the biggest
size, the party size,
368 grams.
That means the biggest bag in the US
is 67.3% larger than the
biggest bag in China.
Oh, it's not the size that
matters, Joe, it's ...
no, wait, no, actually it is the size.
In the US, our flavored bags weigh less
than the original-flavored bags.
Take this bag of barbecue Lay's.
It weighs 7.75 ounces,
compared to the 8 ounces you
get with the original bag.
Same price, but less product.
Back in 2014, PepsiCo claimed, quote,
"The reason for the slightly higher price
per ounce for flavored chips
is the added seasoning."
Interesting!
So, Lay's, can you
explain to me why this bag
of lightly salted chips is
7.75, or 7 ¾, like the flavored bags,
and not 8 ounces, like
the regular salted bags,
where all this has for "seasoning"
is less salt than the original?
Yo, Lay's!
Where's my salt?
A 28-gram bag in the US
supposedly contains 15 chips,
according to Lay's website.
Let's see how accurate this is.
I hate doing this.
I really hate doing this.
We don't have a 28-gram bag,
so I'll count the number of
chips in a 40-gram packet
as a comparison.
It's 1.43 times heavier,
but is it just as plentiful?
Joe: Four.
Tianran: 10. 11.
I'm running out of big chips
now. It's all the small ones.
Yeah, it seems like a lot more than 15.
Closer to 21.
That was very generous of you, Lay's.
I see the finish line.
That's roughly 24.
And ...
oh!
25 chips in a 40-gram packet.
OK, I'm already incredibly impressed
at the number of chips they
managed to fit into this bag,
but they really could've
put more in there,
and we all know that Lay's chip bags
are mostly filled with air anyway.
It's actually nitrogen gas,
which helps preserve the chips
and also acts a cushion to stop them
from getting smashed in transit.
I mean ...
OK.
But what is the
air-to-chip ratio, you ask?
It's a rhetorical
question. Let's find out.
I'm going to take the
smallest packet that we have,
the 12 grams.
So that's 533.3 milliliters.
I feel like I'm on the Food Network.
OK, now we need to find out
the volume of the chips.
15.
Our ratio is
0.028 chips to air,
which makes it 2.8% chips,
and the rest of it is all air.
Incredibly scientifically
accurate experiment yields
525 milliliters in the bag.
Let's do five bags, and then
we'll just get a bigger number,
then divide that by five,
because we'll have an average.
Smart? Great.
Oh, yeah!
You guys have no idea
how satisfying this is.
425 divided by five equals
85.
I forgot what it was.
Can someone do that
on-screen for us, please?
And there's the number
we've been trying to get.
Here are all the Lay's chips from China
that you won't find in the US.
And here are most of the
Lay's chips from the US
you won't find in China.
All right, let's start
with the exclusive flavors
for the classic chip style.
Now, these four are
the most common flavors
that you'll find here
on the Chinese market,
beginning with Italian red meat.
Wow, it's nice and red.
They were probably going
for Bolognese sauce here.
It's not offensive.
But you also can't quite place
what exactly they were trying to do.
Next, we have the Mexican chicken tomato.
Mm!
Oh, that is delicious!
Next, we have the
Texas grilled barbecue flavor.
It tastes savory.
Last but not least, cucumber flavor.
Why? Just why?
I don't know what I'm eating.
What is this?
It's sweet. It's refreshing.
It has an aftertaste of cucumber.
I want to ask why,
but I also kind of, I'm OK with it.
It's kind of nice.
You know, I wonder if these are popular
because they're "foreign" flavors.
Because we don't know
what Italian red meat
or Mexican chicken tomato
is supposed to taste like,
and apparently neither do you guys.
All right, let's move to
our exclusive local flavors.
The spicy crayfish, or
as you guys in the US
would call them, crawfish.
Yes!
That smells legit.
Ugh.
It tastes a little bit less crayfish
than it smells like crayfish.
No, no, that's good, that's good.
Oh, it's got that aftertaste.
Mm.
Wow, that is pretty authentic.
Roasted cumin lamb skewer.
Hands down my
all-time-favorite street food.
This is iconic.
Especially in summer,
you'll see people
hanging out in the alleys
with their tank top rolled up
so their belly is exposed.
We call that the "Beijing bikini" here.
And then they'll be holding
a bunch of these skewers with meat,
just ripping them off and
slamming back the beers.
Ugh! Best things about China
is street food, honestly.
Mm.
No, I can see it's there.
It's not as meaty as I would like,
but then, look, it's a
potato chip, all right?
I think they've done pretty well.
What do we have here?
Seaweed flavor.
Roast-garlic oyster.
I think they should
just rename this lineup
to the street-food edition.
Wasabi flavor.
Oh! Oh!
Ooh-hoo!
If you finish a bag of this,
blocked nose, gone.
Mm.
Fried crab.
Holy crab!
Wow, they've done really well.
Numb and spicy hot pot.
Mm!
Ho-hoo!
It's spicy.
I haven't got the numb yet.
Maybe I need to eat more?
The more you eat hot pot,
the more the broth simmers down,
the spicier it becomes.
So at the end,
your hot pot is way
spicier than at the start.
This feels a little bit
like that right now.
Here we have another popular
flavor from the south,
from Sichuan. This is roast fish.
And we've got a special flavor
from a past season.
Truffle.
Oh!
OK.
Maybe I'm just lowbrow. I don't
like the flavor of truffle.
It tastes like a wet forest.
Ugh. No, thank you.
Hold these up. We have so
many exclusive flavors.
It's quite robust. I was
not able to get all of them,
so these are the ones I could find
here in Southern California.
First one, salt and vinegar.
Come on, China.
I like salt and vinegar better
than plain potato chips.
Sweet Southern heat barbecue.
Different than our regular barbecue.
Sweet and barbecue flavored?
I think I like these better
than regular barbecue chips.
Let's compare.
Regular US barbecue.
Sweet Southern heat.
These are better.
Speaking of barbecue, honey barbecue.
That's just OK. You know,
this is not very honey-ish.
The one with the sweet is sweeter
than the one with honey.
Go figure.
Oh, yeah.
Cheddar and sour cream.
I mean, this thing ...
Yo, top five over here.
These are really good.
We got limón flavor.
These are lime-flavored chips with
I don't know who this person is.
Is this the guy in "Ted Lasso"?
I don't know who this is.
Sazonado. Is that his name?
It's, like, a one —
Yuelei: Doesn't that mean
seasoned or something?
I have no idea.
Yeah.
What?
Lime and potato together?
Who would've thought?
I hate pickles.
But I like dill.
But I should, in theory, like this.
Nope. Ugh.
Go away forever.
Do not like dill-flavored chips.
They also have Flamin'
Hot dill pickle chips.
Couldn't get my hands on a bag.
But I did get my hands on a bag
of just the Flamin' Hot chips.
Oh, man.
That's, like, really red.
Flamin' Hot?
Yeah. Yep.
Spicy, yes. Flavorful, not so much.
Ones I think I'm going
to like. Chili limón.
Not as spicy. Way more flavorful.
Oh, yeah, and the lime aftertaste.
Wow, these are fantastic.
These might be my favorite.
If I had to organize
these in my favorites,
these are my favorite.
These are delicious.
These are all really good.
Everything to here on is
like, would grab, do enjoy.
The honey barbecue is not that sweet.
Flamin' Hot.
Yeah, hot but not really flavorful.
And dill pickle's ... pickles suck.
You can also get the adobadas flavor,
the Dorito's Cool Ranch Lay's flavor,
and a cheddar jalapeño,
which I really wanted to get.
Couldn't get my hands on
it. I was really bummed.
All right, on to our regional limited,
starting with
the spicy chicken with rattan pepper.
Now, this a very popular
dish from Sichuan Province,
down in Southwest China.
That aroma is legit.
Very legit.
This is way more numbing than
the spicy and numbing hot pot.
And more spicy too.
The hot pot strikes back.
This time it's the spicy hot pot.
Nah.
I don't taste the beef oil in there.
I don't get the savory.
Nah, this is meh.
Sesame sauce hot pot.
This is a Cantonese flavor!
Ah!
For once.
This is Sham Tseng roast goose flavor.
Oh!
Oh, well done!
Mm!
Yes! Yes!
Ha! Sham Tseng represent!
Mm!
Marinated chicken feet.
Linyi stir-fried chicken.
Now, this originates
from Shandong Province,
which is over in Eastern China.
They're quite fond of their
stews and braises over there,
meats and vegetables that have been cooked
for a very long time,
so hopefully this will be very flavorful.
OK, so I can taste the
sort of roast-meat flavor.
Especially when you
cook with a Chinese wok,
there's a bit of smokiness
that is attached to the meat
after you've cooked it.
I feel like I'm getting that here.
We're back to the
Sichuanese flavors again.
This is,
it's called laziji.
So it's basically stir-fried chicken
in a mountain of chilies.
You know, the whole point of laziji
is not to eat tons of chicken,
but to find chicken from
within the mountain of chilies.
It's a dish that goes
especially well with beer.
There we go.
We have another hot pot.
This, I think, is the most
pointless kind of hot pot.
This is hot pot for people who can't eat
spicy or numbing hot pot.
For people like you out
there, we have tomato hot pot.
OK, fair enough.
It's quite tasty.
And now for our 2023
spring lineup,
beginning with,
oh!
Salt and pepper mantis shrimp.
What do we have next?
Oh, beef Wellington!
Oh, my God.
Oh.
I'm speechless.
This leaves me very confused.
It just tastes like butter.
And last but not least,
we've got the takoyaki-flavored chips.
These are a Japanese street food.
Mm.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, the smokiness is on point.
We have a bunch of chip-style
varieties in the US,
starting with another thick
chip variety, kettle cooked.
I don't know what it means.
I'm assuming they cook them in a kettle.
I don't know how. I don't know
how they make regular chips.
So many flavors to choose from.
Sea salt and vinegar.
Sea salt and cracked pepper.
Mesquite barbecue.
Jalapeño.
Everyone not in the US, I
want to tell you right now,
these chips, fantastic.
These might be my favorite chips.
These are so good.
Mm!
Other flavors include original,
Flamin' Hot, and Maui onion.
All right, now on to our selection
of wavy and wavy limited,
beginning with our roast chicken wing.
This feels thicker than the
regular chip. Very crunchy.
I'm starting to get the
roast chicken in there.
Yeah, that's decent.
The roast squid.
Not that big a fan of
roast squid, to be honest,
but I will try the roast pork.
It's tasty, but I can't
really get the pork in there.
I think the chicken is still better.
This just says pure spicy,
as if we haven't already
eaten enough spicy chips.
And tomato.
Nah. Nah.
This can stay unopened.
Moving on to our wavy limited.
These are a collaboration
with another snack brand
here in China called Huang Fei Hong,
who make spicy peanuts.
This one is hot and sour chicken feet.
This is the spicy peanut flavor
for which the Huang Fei
Hong brand is best known.
Mm!
Tastes like spicy
peanuts, but in chip form.
OK, I'm sure many of you
must be super curious
as to what this is.
This is Lay's Chocoridge,
which is a collab with a brand
that's literally called Le Cake.
This is their
cheesecake-flavored Chocoridge.
I've never had this either.
A sweet dessert Lay's, wow.
This is so wrong that it's so right.
Wow.
Wow!
Now I have very high
expectations for this.
Now, this is the Chocoridge
chocolate truffle.
Here you can actually see how
it's literally just a regular Lay's crisp
covered in chocolate.
Well done.
This is a good collab.
We have something similar.
Our wavy-style chips.
These are three of the many options
you can get here in the US.
Of course, starting with original.
We also have hickory barbecue.
And I don't even know what this is.
This is like they combined
Funyuns and wavy together.
Oh, these are weird.
Skip those.
You can also get wavy,
reduced-fat original,
wavy ranch, wavy salt and pepper,
and wavy lightly salted.
Now on to our non-potato options,
of which we have a lot.
These are all yam.
Yams have subcategories of yam crisps
and yam rolls as well.
These are the black sesame
and chia seed yam crisps.
Man, they sound healthy, don't they?
So, in traditional Chinese medicine,
black sesame is thought
to help with hair growth.
I've been recommended it a lot.
I can taste the nuttiness
of the black sesame.
Mm.
And I feel like my hairline
is coming back any moment now.
This is also something that adheres
to traditional Chinese medicine.
Chinese dates and goji berries.
These are delicious.
Wow.
Here we have pastoral tomatoes?
Roast chicken wing.
On to our yam rolls.
These are an upgraded version
of the crisps that you see.
This is steak with Tartary buckwheat.
These things are so wafer thin.
They have this amazing crunch.
They're airy, they're light.
The very slight bitterness
of the buckwheat
lends itself very well to the steak.
Fragrant red stew,
consisting of yam and highland barley,
which is the main cereal
planted on the Tibetan High Plateau.
We also have taro and sweet potato chips.
This is one with black
pepper and sea salt.
It's very thin, yet it's not crispy.
It feels almost a little bit soggy.
Refreshing lime. [sighs]
What's with all the refreshing chips?
Pass.
Sweet potato chips.
Natural flavor.
I know this probably
frustrates some of you at home,
but the majority of people here in China
open crisp packets like this,
as opposed to horizontally,
like in the West,
because it's easier to open
this way, easier to share.
When you reach in, you don't
get salt stuck to your hand.
And it's also just less effort.
We don't need to brute
way our way into things.
Not going to lie. It's not so bad.
So, we had the regular
sweet sweet-potato chips.
Now we have sweet potato
chips with added brown sugar.
Ugh!
Why? No!
I'm going to waste as little
time as possible on these,
baked chips. They're just for people
who want their chips to be
more brittle and less flavored.
I don't know. These suck.
You have original or barbecue.
Here's original.
I mean, this is the third
time we've done this.
Don't bother.
Just trust me, don't bother.
Listen to this.
[chips rattling]
They're all destroyed in there.
They have no taste. They're flimsy.
The baked are bad.
There's the Better for
You and Simply brand.
The Better for You is the lightly salted,
lightly salted barbecue,
wavy lightly salted.
All these right here.
I get it.
Sodium can be an issue
for snacking chips a lot,
so why not go with the lightly salted?
I mean, 50% less sodium?
That's pretty good, right?
I mean, how do these,
I'm curious how these compare to ...
These have 50% less?
This is 100% less.
I don't taste anything.
Also, the Simply,
I guess the whole deal is they
just use simpler ingredients.
"Made with three simple ingredients,
potato, sunflower oil, and sea salt."
There's also the Simply
barbecue thick cut.
I mean, how much better could it be?
We also have two exclusives
from the Simply lineup,
which have 50% less saturated fat.
The refreshing lime and the seaweed.
Guess what?
We even have Lay's french fries.
Let's go with the original flavor.
These come in really
big packets, by the way.
It's so incredibly salty.
I am so glad that they only
gave us this tiny packet,
because I am going to just ...
no, I don't want the rest.
Ugh.
Cheese and butter french fries.
Pink grapefruit flavor.
I mean, you can't see this and not try it.
This is really good!
This is so weird, but it's really good.
Hot pink grapefruit Lay's.
I'm going to pick that up and eat it.
It's that good.
Mm!
We also have seaweed-flavor french fries
and tomato-flavor french fries.
But I am dying to try this.
Purple potato french fries.
Ugh.
I don't even know what that tastes like.
No.
Now, we have one more
non-potato-chip Lay's.
The air-fried chicken breast.
I have absolutely no idea
how much chicken is in here.
It looks like very tiny
pizzas or little crackers.
It leaves me very confused.
I do taste the chicken.
But, hey, this is an interesting flavor.
Ugh!
Stax.
Stax!
If you've seen any other
Lay's "Food Wars" we've done,
I hate these for every reason.
They are Pringle-shaped chips
in plastic tubes instead of plastic bags.
First of all, worst container. Right?
[chips rattling]
Does that sound like
some chips are intact?
These chips are really messed up, man.
Not a pleasant experience at all,
but I'm contractually
obligated to tell you,
besides these two flavors,
you can also get Stax
in mesquite barbecue,
cheddar, salt and vinegar,
bacon and cheddar potato skins,
Buffalo wings with
ranch, Xtra Flamin' Hot,
Flamas, and chile limón.
Please don't get them.
Trust me, they suck.
We've got Stax too!
And in many more flavors, as you can tell.
Stax is basically Lay's
take on the Pringles.
But whereas Pringles took 10 years
to come up with their saddle-shaped chip,
which is actually known as
a double-curved hyperbolic paraboloid,
Stax went with a
single-curved hyperbolic cylinder.
So you can actually see the difference
in the shape of the chip right here.
The Stax, by the way,
comes with a fancy-schmancy
plastic tray
that's meant to keep it from breaking
but hasn't worked very well in this case.
Here is an intact Stax,
and here is an intact Pringle.
To be honest, they kind of look similar.
The Pringle has an extra curve down here,
whereas the Stax down here
appears to be a bit more flat.
Now, the Stax also comes in tomato flavor.
Cucumber flavor.
There are some flavors
that I would love to try,
such as the sizzled barbecue flavor.
Da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da. Oh, wow!
This is a good plastic tray.
Yeah, it tastes all right.
Black pepper rib eye steak.
This I am actually very excited to try.
Finger-licking red braised pork.
There's maybe a hint of pork in there.
And some sugar and some caramelizing,
but that's pretty much it.
OK, we've got one for
you Stax fans out there.
These are the Stax
premium, the Stax black.
The Chinese name actually
says "potato workshop."
And apparently, it has
real food ingredients.
So, this is avocado with mustard.
Why?
OK, now we have purple potato,
so basically sweet potato,
with coconut milk.
Maybe it's an acquired taste.
Hoo!
I mean, you guys know I don't
like truffle now anyway.
I'm pretty lowbrow.
But this is black-truffle-
and black-pepper-flavored potato chip.
Spanish-ham-flavored potato chips.
I love me some Ibérico jamón.
I am praying that this
is going to be tasty.
Fire them all. They're rubbish.
This is spicy crawfish.
Mm!
Oh! Yes!
OK, finally we have a winner
from the Stax premium lineup.
This is great.
And I would say that this
tastes even more authentic
than the regular-potato-chip version
of the spicy crayfish that we had earlier.
Oh!
Roast chicken skewer.
Wagyu beef.
Sour and sweet rose petals.
Oh, come on, Lay's, you are
just playing with me now.
This is delicious.
Wow.
Imagine sitting in a nice,
warm, milky bath,
floating with rose petals
and eating this sweet and
sour rose petal Lay's.
Wow!
That would be the best evening ever.
Wow.
This is great, fantastic.
We have a seaweed flavor.
I like my seaweed. We've
had too much seaweed today.
I'm pretty sure this is going to be OK.
We also got Poppables.
These are so stupid.
What is this?
We don't need a new shape.
Tell everyone in the biz.
We don't need new shapes.
So, I don't know what this
thing's supposed to be,
but you can get it in
sea salt, honey barbecue,
sea salt and vinegar, white cheddar.
Like, look at this.
It's all hollow inside.
Ugh!
It's like a giant Chex.
What are we doing here?
Lay's, what are we doing here?
Why? What? What?
What?
Now, I know, Lay's, it seems
I'm going hard on you guys.
But I have to say, ending with the dips,
Lay's dips are fantastic.
They have three to choose from.
The smooth ranch, the French onion,
and the creamy jalapeño. Couldn't get it.
This French onion dip is drugs.
Any chip works with it.
Let's do my favorite kettle, jalapeño.
Stellar.
This dip works on literally everything.
I would put this in my coffee if I could.
It is so great. Fantastic.
The dips are great. Check them out.
A 75-gram bag of American
classic Lay's in China
is 7.3 yuan,
or $1.06.
Our closest size to the 75-gram bag
is the 74.4-gram bag, so 0.6 grams less.
And it's $2.48, or 17.04 yuan.
That is a 134% cost increase in the US.
Right, but then if you take into account
purchasing-power parity,
then Lay's charges the
highest price in the world
for its chips here in China.
So, here in China, even
though the chip market
only accounts for 15%
of the snack industry,
Lay's accounts for 50%
of that chip market.
These guys are definitely
the crème de la crème
when it comes to potato
chips here in China,
and they've got such a
wide variety of flavors
that you will see them always
in a prime shelf location
in every convenience
store across the country.
Lay's in the US, Lay's
is, like, the chip, right?
There's other chip brands, but Lay's,
probably the most ubiquitous.
You see them everywhere.
They have so many different
options and styles.
I think any type of potato chip
that is even remotely popular,
Lay's has a knockoff version of it.
Always good, always available,
always decently priced, I guess?
I think Lay's has been incredible
in adapting to the Chinese market.
They've basically gone and found
all of the popular flavors
and combinations in China,
whether it's street
food or restaurant food,
and put them into a convenient
and portable chip packet.
Lay's is incredible at adapting
because, as you saw before,
every style they have, besides
the regular potato chip,
is a style that another chip brand had
that they just took on.
The kettle chips, they taste
just like Miss Vickie's.
They got the wavy ones,
which was Ruffles, right?
The Poppables, which, I don't know,
Bugles, Chex, you tell me.
Any three-dimensional chip.
The Stax, which is going after Pringles.
I mean, they're
bloodthirsty, this company.
They will go after anyone!
Our classic Lay's, aka
the American flavor,
are made of potatoes, oil,
American classic original seasoning,
which is comprised of edible
salt, monosodium glutamate,
5'-flavor nucleotide disodium,
and silicon dioxide.
Our classic Lay's are made up of potatoes;
vegetable oil, which is canola, corn,
soybean, and/or sunflower oil; and salt.
Now, there are two ingredients
we wanted to highlight,
which are monosodium glutamate, aka MSG,
and 5'-flavor nucleotide disodium.
These two ingredients are
used to give our chips
a savory, umami flavor.
Ah, MSG.
It's the black sheep of condiments.
Now, for those of you who
don't know what MSG is,
it's used to add savoriness to food
and was also associated
with something called
"Chinese restaurant syndrome,"
which has since been debunked many times.
Turns out it was a hoax.
But basically, the gist is,
when you go to a Chinese restaurant,
after eating its food,
you'll feel headaches,
dizziness, sore throat, loss of appetite.
You know, MSG is not the culprit.
It's naturally occurring in
tomatoes, in bone broths;
it's found in fermented foods, from cheese
to Worcestershire sauce to soy sauce;
and actually the vast
majority of MSG in the world
is made through fermentation,
just like yogurt or vinegar.
MSG was a cause for health
concerns in the US for decades.
And concern still lingers today,
even though the FDA considers
the addition of MSG to foods
as being generally
recognized as safe, GRAS.
Both countries use the food coloring
caramel color in our barbecue chips.
Now, certain types of caramel color
contain a byproduct called 4-MeI.
4-Methylimidazole.
And studies found that it
caused cancer in rats and mice,
which led to campaigns calling for it
to be banned from foods.
But it's also worth
noting that this byproduct
is found when you roast
foods like coffee and meat.
And the FDA was like, "Eh, it's fine."
Humans don't come close
to the levels of exposure
that caused the rat tumors.
That didn't stop the state of California
adding it to its Proposition
65 list of chemicals, quote,
"Known to the state of
California to cause cancer
or reproductive toxicity."
End quote.
A 30-gram of packet of China Lay's
American classic-flavor chips
contains 162 calories,
1.7 grams of protein,
10.5 grams of fat,
of which 5.3 grams are saturated fats,
15.1 grams of carbs,
of which 0.4 grams are sugars,
0.8 grams of fiber,
and 170 milligrams of sodium.
A 20-gram bag of classic
Lay's in the US contains
160 calories, total fat 10 grams,
of which saturated, 1.5 grams.
Carbs, 15 grams, and 170
milligrams of sodium.
We did find that the 160-calorie chips
with the highest fat content
are the cheddar and sour cream chips.
Here's what's in a bag of those.
160 calories, 10 grams of fat,
of which 1.5 are saturated.
15 grams of carbs, and
170 milligrams of sodium.
Dun, dun, dun!
We have a very shocking discovery.
Apparently, Lay's "healthiest" chips
are in fact their least healthy,
in that they have more calories on average
than any other Lay's
product here in China.
And the worst offender
is my hair-growth serum,
the black sesame and chia seed yam crisps.
Now, 100 grams of this will equal
598.7 calories,
or 168 calories
for a 28-gram packet.
Now, in a 30-gram portion,
you'll have 179.6 calories,
1.6 grams of protein,
13.3 grams of fat,
of which 6.6 are saturated fat,
13.7 grams of carbs,
and 212 milligrams of sodium.
Which means that the healthy yam chips
are on average 11% more calorific
than any other Lay's chips,
containing less protein and carbs
and more sodium and fat.
You know, I always thought
healthy just meant not tasty,
but in Lay's case, apparently,
it also means less healthy.
What a plot twist.
From calorie count to portion sizes,
we wanted to find out all the differences
between Burger King in
the US and in China.
This is "Food Wars."
Hey, it's Joe.
I'm busy working on some
cool new videos for you.
I will not be able to host today,
but I want to introduce
you to my good friend Nico.
I trust Nico's going
to do a fantastic job.
All the "Food Wars"-heads
watching, make her feel welcome.
Take it away, Nico.
Here in China, our Burger King
drinks come in three sizes:
small, medium, and large.
In the US, our Burger King
drinks come in four sizes:
value, which we weren't able to get,
small, medium, and large.
Let's see how much our largest
drink actually contains.
I'm kind of OK with it.
They're lying to me.
Our Burger King fries
also come in three sizes:
small, medium, and large.
Our fries come in four sizes:
value, small, medium, and large.
Let's weigh our largest fries. 120.
140 grams. Liars again.
This is the second lie I've
been told in like five minutes.
I think Joe and Harry
have beef with Burger King
ever since #frygate2020.
They discovered the small and medium sizes
were the same size, allegedly.
Allegedly. I do not want to get sued.
But let's see if both of them
actually do weigh the same.
I don't think that I have to
count every individual fry,
because that is a very big difference.
I think there's clearly
some discrepancies going on.
Just for fun, let's
weigh these value fries.
These are 98.
What's happening?
What's going on at Burger King?
So I guess you can get away
with just ordering a value size
for, like, way less money
if this is what's going on.
Our chicken fries come in one size only
and should contain six fries.
Ta-da.
No way to escape from giving
us the full amount here, BK.
There's only six of them.
Ours is also one size: nine chicken fries.
One, two, three, four, five,
six, seven, eight, nine.
This is the first time
that Burger King hasn't
lied straight to my face.
Let's begin with our beef burgers.
We can start with the King's Collection,
which I guess are BK's premium burgers.
Whereas the Whoppers
are known as Emperors,
but they're cheaper than the kings.
I can just hear the nationalists
starting to get angry already.
How could a king be more powerful
and more expensive than an emperor?
What gives?
You obviously haven't
localized properly, BK.
You need to know your audience.
Beginning with the pastrami Angus.
It's not something that you see very often
here in China to begin with.
So in in Chinese,
the name is called the
"bigmouth Angus burger,"
because the burger itself is
meant to be quite a tall burger.
But this is a very beautiful
burger, and I must say,
I am very impressed that it
has not come to us sloppy
and completely crushed into paste,
which was the case that we found
with other fast-food chains.
I'm not going to name
names. [cough] [bleep]
Very dense.
I did have to open my mouth pretty wide.
And I can't quite taste the pastrami,
but I like that it's there.
Here we've got the classic Angus.
You can also get the spicy version,
which is what I've opted for.
Ooh, ooh.
Oh, that's a spicy fella.
This is actually pretty interesting.
It's not the Sichuan spicy kind of heat
that I've gotten used to here
eating other localized burgers in China,
but this is more sort of a
straight-up, in-your-face heat.
Lot of black pepper, and
the caramelized onions,
oh, they pair very well in this burger.
Introducing the heavy cheese beef King.
So heavy, actually, it even
crushed the box that it came in.
Well, hello. The spicy bamboo
shoots beef chicken Whopper.
That is such a long name.
It came in this box.
These are characters from
a massive game in China
called the Honor of Kings. It's a MOBA.
The company that makes
this bought Riot Games,
which made "League of Legends."
The fact that it has this collab,
I mean, that means something.
I just want to say it tastes very Chinese
in the best possible way.
It feels like I'm in
Southwest China right now,
playing a game of Honor
of Kings and losing badly.
Because otherwise,
how would I have time to eat
burgers if I'm not respawning?
Final member of the King Collection is
the Italian spinach bacon Angus.
Oh, one thing that irks
me a little bit about
bacon in burgers in China is that
they're this kind of bacon. They're wet.
And what's the point of eating
bacon if it's not crispy?
Oh, my God.
BK burgers are so incredibly dense.
They're like the burger
versions of diamonds.
Moving on to our classic burgers.
This is the
king oyster mushroom
beef Whopper Thai basil flavor.
My God, not only are
their burgers mouthfuls,
but so are the names.
You can actually see the oyster mushrooms.
Look, right here.
Let's give this mouthful a mouthful.
It feels like I'm in the gym
about to do some really heavy lifting.
[exhales]
And then [grunts].
Another classic, the
grilled pineapple Whopper.
One gigantic pineapple ring.
If I had two more hands so, oh.
The pork cubes and beef burger.
Who names these things?
The pork cubes that it refers to is
pork neck.
It's a meat lover's heaven, isn't it?
I can do this!
Feeling like my jaw's about to break.
Oh, yes.
Wow.
That is amazing.
This pork neck is just
absolutely delicious.
Moving on to our value section,
we've got the spicy Whopper Jr.
Oh, look at this little guy.
You can also get the
pineapple bacon Whopper Jr.
also in this size.
This is our bacon corner.
So we have the bacon King, and
there is a bacon cheeseburger
and the double bacon cheeseburger.
I really want to taste the bacon King.
That's, like, a big burger
for fast food, right?
That is heavy, too.
My face is bigger,
but it doesn't smell as
good as this burger does.
Kind of tastes like a
burger right off the grill.
This is, like, insane how big they are.
Now let's move on to the Whoppers.
I think these are definitely
Burger King's claim to fame.
It's what they're most known for.
This is the Texas Double Whopper.
This kind of looks like the
Mondo Burger from "Good Burger."
That is not ASMR.
What's the opposite of ASMR?
And the last Whopper we have
is the Impossible Whopper,
which I actually think
tastes pretty delicious.
Like, this looks like a hamburger
from a play food set I had as a child.
It just doesn't look very real.
This looks like a monster.
I do want to take a bite of
the Texas double Whopper,
just because it's got
a lot of stuff in it.
That is so good.
Oh my God, it's really spicy.
And here we have our single
Rodeo Clown King burger.
[camera crew laughs]
Single Rodeo Burger King pounder.
All of them share the exact
same words. It's crazy.
And here we have the
single quarter-pound King
and the Rodeo burger, which I
think has onion rings in it.
I was wrong.
OK, pretend I said the opposite.
So this is the Rodeo burger,
and it's got onion rings
and what looks like sticky barbecue sauce.
It's just a little congealed in there.
I think it could be good.
It's just not very good.
Now let's move on to the
chicken sandwiches, or burgers,
whichever you prefer.
As for chicken, you can
get the chicken Whopper,
coming in classic or spicy flavors.
You can get the grilled pineapple
chicken Whopper as well.
Next we've got the chicken Big King.
Now the Big King is a
collection, and we have beef,
which is not exclusive here in China,
but chicken and fish are.
And it's basically kind
of like a Big Mac in that
there are two patties
and a bun in the middle.
That's a lot of bread.
This here is the fruitwood
grilled chicken burger.
Spicy chicken burger.
The chicken is threatening to escape.
Oh, yeah, the more you chew it, mm.
The more you chew it, the
more flavorful it becomes.
And now I can,
it's almost like a
thermometer in my mouth.
I can,
I can feel the spiciness rising up.
I swallowed just now,
and my saliva is spicy.
We have the crispy chicken sandwich.
But what makes this a
sandwich and this a burger?
I have no idea.
There's also a double version of that,
excuse my lettuce,
that is called the double chicken burger.
So if it's a single, it's
a crispy chicken sandwich,
but if it's a double, then it
just becomes something else.
Anyway, this also comes in
original or rattan pepper flavor.
Here we have the chicken version
of the Italian spinach bacon Whopper.
A surprise for you all,
this is new on the menu.
Da-da-da.
The black cheese and
crispy chicken sandwich.
So this thing is not nori.
This is actually a slice of cheddar cheese
that's been dyed black with squid ink,
because just why not?
So if you thought this
was weird, check this out.
This is the black cheese
and crispy chicken burger.
Most importantly, instead of the bun,
they've replaced it with
two pieces of black cheese.
Mind blown.
I think this is basically
just an excuse for you
to not feel guilty about eating
a piece of spicy chicken by
itself without the bread.
It's basically just there as, like, tissue
to help you eat this thing.
We have two chicken exclusives,
the original chicken
sandwich and the Chicken Jr.
This shape is actually very
unique and pretty iconic.
In a world of circular chicken sandwiches,
this stands out to me.
Usually the chicken sandwiches
I see look like this.
Just you know, nothing special.
But this is special.
BK also offers fish exclusives.
Here we've got the Fish'N Crisp,
which I believe uses a cod fillet.
And of course, the fish
version of the Big King.
And of course, we also have a pork section
comprising of two burgers,
the pork neck and beef burger,
which I took a nice big
chunk out of before.
And the chicken version
of this pork burger.
And here is our fish option, the Big Fish.
This is the smoothest bun I've ever seen.
Look how shiny and beautiful that is.
It's not offensive,
not particularly great.
These are our exclusive snacks
here in Burger King China.
I feel like they're encroaching
on KFC territory a little bit,
because all of this is chicken.
We've got the mala chicken drumstick.
So "mala" literally just
means numb and spicy,
and it's referring to the
Sichuanese style of cooking
with the peppercorn,
which gives you the
numbness and the chili heat.
Oh, wow.
I feel like this is probably
the strongest mala flavor
that I've had thus far on Food Wars.
It's starting to turn my tongue numb.
I'm quite pleasantly surprised.
Here we've got the petite
version, the mala chicken wings.
This here, the King hot
and spicy chicken wings.
Oh, man, I much prefer it
over the mala to be honest.
This is a lot more balanced,
it's more flavorful, it's meatier.
So these are called the
spicy flavor chicken slices.
Apparently it's 4-millimeter thin
slices of chicken breast.
It just kind of looks like mini
chicken nuggets, doesn't it?
This is the chicken box,
which contains a medley of
what we sampled earlier.
So Burger King also has other versions of
the bucket, the box, whatever
you'd like to call it.
They've got the King chicken
bucket, the King bucket,
and the King bucket plus.
They're basically the BK version of
the party bucket or family bucket.
For those of you who
could not get enough of
the black cheese,
you can also get it as a standalone piece.
Just one piece of good old cheddar cheese
dyed black with squid ink.
Oh, BK, you are so funny.
You can always opt for the garden salad.
And here in Chinese it actually says,
"Mama is shouting at you,
telling you to eat more veggies."
And these are our exclusive side options.
We have onion rings.
Don't mind if I do.
They're soggy.
And we also have mozzarella sticks,
which I feel like at this
point are fully congealed
back into their, like, frozen state.
These were supposed to
come with a marinara sauce.
I don't think I got one.
We also have Mott's applesauce as a side,
but they unfortunately ran out.
And here are our exclusive sauces.
We have buffalo, ranch,
honey mustard, and zesty.
I know what pretty much all
of these sauces taste like,
except for zesty.
I'm very confused as
to what this could be.
Just watch this one for you guys,
just so you can see what it
looks like on my skin tone.
This is the most disturbing,
stupid thing I've ever done.
Horseradish-y.
I feel like zesty gives
me like, ooh, zesty.
This is like, ugh, zesty.
It's nasty.
Time for dessert.
We can start with the
Ovaltine King Fusion.
This comes in original strawberry
and brown sugar bubble flavor.
The Ovaltine was the little
sort of brown flakes on top.
That's what tastes like milk chocolate.
Not bad. It's not as sweet
as I thought it would be.
Ovaltine King Fusion,
brown sugar bubble edition.
Very elusive these days.
Where are they?
Ah, here we go.
Mm, delicious.
Once upon a time,
this was the Hokkaido flavor
ice cream waffle cone.
It tastes like melted ice cream.
I can't tell.
If you say it's Hokkaido,
I'm none the wiser.
This is the crispy
chocolate and nuts sundae.
Häagen-Dazs, Ben and Jerry,
get out the way, BK's in town.
Look at that. That looks luxe.
Look at how much chocolate is in here.
This is basically half a bar
of chocolate in ice cream.
There's nothing that
could be better than this.
I think it's peanut.
I'm not sure. Who cares?
Oh, it's delicious.
And the strawberry pulp sundae.
Actual strawberry in the sundae.
Color me impressed.
Now this pie comes in
two different flavors:
dark chocolate or mango and coconut.
Let me check which one this is.
I think it's a telltale sign.
I think it's probably the chocolate.
Deep-fried chocolate, what could go wrong?
These are called crispy thick milk bars.
It's creamy, but it doesn't
really taste like much.
This is the soft mochi ice cream.
And it comes in two flavors,
strawberry yogurt and salted egg.
Wow.
It's kind of like a custard.
Oh, this kind of tastes like
what would happen if you took
the heart out of a moon cake
and liquefied it and just drank it.
Oh, my God,
I think I'm seeing stars from
my blood sugar spiking. Oh.
Let's talk about desserts.
At Burger King in the US,
you can get a soft-serve cup,
a soft-serve cone, or
the Hershey's sundae pie.
This was one of my favorite
things ever as a kid.
I would always get it every
time we went to Burger King.
Look at this.
It literally says yum on every
side, because it's that good.
They look exactly the
same as when I was little.
That is so delicious.
These are the exclusive drinks
on the Burger King China menu.
Looks weird, doesn't it?
It just looks like 7Up.
But this is actually coconut-flavored
lemon sparkling drink.
Peach-flavored oolong tea.
This is the brown sugar boba milk tea.
You can get this hot or cold.
And also, if you take away the boba balls,
it'll just basically become
the Hong Kong-style milk tea,
which you can also get hot or cold.
The crispy chocolate snow-top milk tea.
You can also get Ceylon tea,
which is just black tea,
or hot or cold soy milk, which this is.
You can get juice too,
grapefruit juice and mixed-berries juice.
Next we have the King coffee collection.
And this is just honestly
the cutest cup ever.
You can get your latte or your flat white,
your hazelnut latte, or cappuccino
in this very, very cute squat cup.
Or if you don't like being cute,
you can just opt for a
regular-sized Americano.
Drink exclusives in the US include
Coke zero, Sprite zero, Barq's root beer,
Dr Pepper, Fanta orange,
Mellow Yello, Powerade zero,
High-C fruit punch, and
High-C pink lemonade.
It's a fast food restaurant,
so of course they also offer
milkshakes and frozen beverages.
We have a vanilla milkshake,
a chocolate milkshake,
an Oreo milkshake,
a chocolate Oreo milkshake.
This is a frozen Fanta wild cherry.
And this is supposed to be a frozen Coke,
but it's another frozen Fanta wild cherry.
We've been putting the
people at Burger King
through a lot today, so
some mistakes were made.
They also supposedly offer
a strawberry milkshake,
but that wasn't available
at our Burger King.
[bleep] has a better vanilla milkshake.
All right, let's try this
frozen Fanta wild cherry.
Is this, this is basically
just a slushy, right?
That's very good.
These are Burger King China's
exclusive breakfast menus.
OK, so just like McDonald's and KFC,
Burger King also does
a pretty decent breakfast
menu here in China.
Not quite as extensive as KFC,
and nowhere near as
exhaustive as McDonald's,
but what Burger King has over both of them
is the Croissan'wich.
I love croissant sandwiches.
Although it's kind of weird how in China,
they're not called by their actual names,
but they're called croissants.
So this is the standard Croissan'wich,
or as we call it here in China,
the pork, egg, and cheese croissant.
Next, we have the pastrami
and scrambled egg croissant.
In Chinese, we would call it yangqi,
which kind of means like
Western style of BK.
I mean, obviously it's Western style,
but the fact that you have
pastrami and scrambled egg,
this combination just
seems very, very foreign
to Chinese culture.
And I think in a cool way, this is great,
just staying true to BK's roots.
Mm, I love pastrami.
What do we got here?
The beef, egg, cheese croissant.
And last but not least
in our croissant series, butter croissant,
which is just ...
All right, BK, you made
this a seasonal menu item.
I don't understand what
it has to do with seasons.
It's literally just two pieces
of your croissant bread.
This is the double egg and beef burger.
Two eggs with two beef patties
sandwiched in between.
No bread whatsoever.
There is no way you can safely
get away with eating this
without making a mess of yourself.
Now on to your more standard fare,
the grilled beef cheese muffin.
You can also get this grilled
beef, cheese, egg muffin.
Oh, now we have something special.
The tamagoyaki and fruitwood flavor
grilled chicken muffin.
Look at that.
Mm.
Oh, this is delicious.
Well, I highly recommend it.
And if you don't want beef in your muffin,
you can get it as a cheese egg muffin.
If you don't want egg nor beef,
then you can get it as
a grilled pork muffin.
BK also has an assortment
of breakfast wraps.
The scrambled egg and cheese sausage wrap.
Beijing-style roasted chicken wrap.
No leek. Just the cucumbers
and the tianmian sauce.
We're missing the last item
on the holy trinity of
the Beijing-style wrap.
You know, it's inoffensive.
That's all I can say.
This is something special.
Salted egg yolk chicken wrap.
The salted egg yolk is actually smeared
all over the chicken here.
Wow, that's very ingenious of BK.
There's no mistaking that salted egg, wow.
Texture-wise, it's like,
it's an egg yolk that has been matured.
Kind of like a fine vintage
egg, if that makes sense.
And last but not least,
we've got the mixed vegetable
and roasted chicken wrap.
And of course, we've got to have congee.
Two types, this is century
egg and this is salted egg.
Give the century egg a try.
Whoo.
Oh, yeah, that's pretty strong.
There's a very, very fine
line between tasty and stinky,
and century egg firmly
straddles that line.
I've never had salted egg
yolk in a congee before.
Congee's not my favorite breakfast item,
but I think with this kind of flavoring,
like, yeah, I can dig it.
And of course, on every
single breakfast menu,
there's going to be crispy
Chinese cruller, the youtiao.
They all look the same
no matter which fast food chain you go to.
BK also has a sunny-side-up egg,
although again, you can't
really tell where the sun is.
Ho ho, this is pretty interesting.
The bean paste glutinous rice balls.
We call them matuan,
which kind of means sesame pile, mound.
These have a really interesting history.
They originated in the Tang dynasty
over 1,000 years ago
and were served up in
the imperial kitchen.
And actually, you'll find that
a lot of traditional Chinese desserts,
especially here in Beijing,
were originally served to the emperor.
The sort of stuff that we eat now
would have been the crème de
la crème back in the old days,
centuries ago, when emperors ruled China.
History in a mouthful.
I'd say it's OK.
It's probably not the tastiest
sesame mound I've ever had,
but, you know,
this isn't made for emperors,
because otherwise it'll
be [clicks tongue].
Off with your head.
Egg bacon pie.
Oh, that's pretty tasty.
The nostalgia's coming back in.
I just remember growing up in the UK
and then going down to Greggs
and getting a nice pasty
in the morning, oh.
I've actually never had
Burger King breakfast.
In the US, our breakfast sandwiches
all come with different variations of
sausage, bacon, ham, egg, and cheese.
And they come in either a
croissant, biscuit or melt form.
We couldn't get the melt form,
but we do have the
croissant and the biscuit
in the loaded versions.
Loaded just means that they
come with all of the toppings.
They look like they're about to burst.
So I believe that's true.
In America, this is a biscuit.
The salt that just got into,
I'm like, I felt all
the moisture in my body
just disappear with that one bite.
That was crazy.
Here are all the different
breakfast sandwich combinations
that you can make at
Burger King in the US.
So you can also get
the Egg-Normous burrito
or its baby, if you don't
want that much of a burrito
before like 10 a.m.
We also have sweeter breakfast options,
like these pancakes with the sausage
and the French toast sticks.
It literally feels like I
am chewing gum right now.
That is crazy how stretchy
and bouncy it is right now.
They smell a little old,
like they were just refried.
It's also chewy, just like the pancakes,
but a lot less disturbing in the mouth.
So Burger King entered China in 2005,
which actually makes it late to the game.
KFC and McD's had already been here
for a decade by that point.
And Chinese consumers know
what Western fast food is like already.
BK cultivates a slightly different image,
one of slightly more prestige.
And you'll find them
mostly in major cities,
top-tier cities like Beijing, Shanghai,
less so in smaller cities.
I feel like in the US,
Burger King has the reputation
of being somewhat fresher
when it comes to ingredients.
Maybe it's considered
on the more fresher side
when it comes to American fast food,
even though it's probably not.
It's pretty funny.
In the past, Burger
King has been criticized
for its bad customer service,
for its rude servers.
And the main thing was you
couldn't even complain,
because they didn't have
a complaints hotline.
So they're kind of like,
take it or leave it.
Convenience, speed of service,
that totally depends on
your specific Burger King.
Is it fast food still? Yes.
You still get the food in
around 10 to 15 minutes.
It's just, will you be
getting what you ordered?
Who knows?
That's part of the fun.
I would say that Burger King,
out of McDonald's and KFC,
is the least localized.
And so they're cultivating
maybe the image of being
a gourmet burger joint,
a sort of a go-between
regular fast food chain
and an actual gourmet burger restaurant.
When it comes to how they
adapt to local taste,
I feel like there's nothing
that special on the menu.
It's pretty normal American fast food.
They did have that one
special Texas Whopper,
which, I've never been to Texas,
so I can't really speak
on how accurate that is.
But it tasted really good.
So in terms of competition,
Burger King is actually fifth in China,
behind KFC, McDonald's,
Wallace Burger and Chicken,
which is a local brand,
and Dicos, another local brand.
McDonald's has to be Burger
King's biggest rival.
As we're filming this in early May,
we've gotten word that Burger King is
closing around 300 to 400 locations.
A Whopper is 27 yuan. That's $3.92.
In the US, a Whopper costs $7.89,
which is an 101.3% price increase
compared to China's Whopper.
Make it a meal with a medium
fry and a medium drink,
and the price goes up to
40 yuan, which is $5.80.
Add a medium fry and
a drink to your order,
and that brings the price up to $11.99,
which is an 106.7% increase in price.
And if you want to upgrade to large,
then that's 44 yuan, which is $6.38.
Make it a large in the US, and
the price goes up to $12.59,
which is a 97% increase in price.
Just in general, I've
found that Burger King
tends to be slightly more
expensive than McDonald's and KFC.
China's Burger King doesn't share
its nutritional information,
but here are a few noteworthy moments
from the last couple of years.
In 2020, Burger King
apologized to its customers
when it was reported that
some of their locations
had sold expired food.
So a Burger King in Nanchang,
which is a major city in eastern China,
had used expired ingredients
to make its burgers.
And get this, there was
actually video footage of staff
replacing the date labels
on the expired bread
with new ones.
And another Burger King
in exactly the same city
did the same thing with expired chicken.
Burger King responded with, and I quote,
"Our mismanagement has betrayed
the trust of consumers to Burger King,
and we express our deepest
apologies for this."
End quote.
This caused China to probe further
into other US fast food chains
like KFC and McDonald's.
Burger King, along with
McDonald's, was sued last year
for using PFAS,
or "forever chemicals,"
in their packaging.
Forever chemicals?
It's in my body forever?
Consumer reports found PFAS in
the French toast sticks bags,
Whopper wrappers, and chicken nugget bags.
We ate like two out of
those three things today.
Oh, my God.
PFAS are chemicals that
are hard to break down
and last a long time,
which are not good for the environment.
And PFAS exposure has been linked
to health problems in humans.
Burger King has responded
in saying, quote,
That's not soon enough.
- From calorie counts to portion sizes.
We wanted to find out all the
differences between Subway
in the US and in China.
This is Food Wars.
Here in China standard Subway subs
come in two sizes, six inch and
twelve inch.
They've done us the favor of
cutting our 12 inch sub in half.
How very kind.
In the US, our subs also come in two sizes
a six inch or a twelve inch,
also known as the foot long.
We're gonna measure both of these
with the tape measure to make sure
that those lengths are actually correct.
What does it look like?
Is it right?
Is it good?
I would say it's like
maybe a few centimeters
off of 12 inches
but it's close enough
like I don't think you're
gonna notice a few centimeters
of sandwich missing.
I'll give you a pass
Subway, that's that's fine.
That's about 30.8 centimeters.
12.12598 inches.
That one is six inches for sure.
About 15 centimeters.
5.9055 inches.
We can also get sub platters in the us.
Ours are the exact same size.
Five 12 inch subs cut into 15 pieces.
That is a lot of sandwich.
It's very, very heavy.
It's really heavy.
I'm gonna leave it there.
We used to have sub
platters and party subs
but shows over folks.
No more parties on this
side of the Pacific.
How's it look for Nico?
We used to have party subs in the US
but Subway overhauled and
streamlined its menu last year
and now seems to have
stopped offering them.
Somebody check on Joe right now
'cause I know he is devastated.
Moving on from subs.
Drinks at a Chinese Subway
only come in one size medium.
That's just sad.
Drinks at a US Subway come in
four sizes, small 21 ounces
medium 30 ounces or
large, which is 40 ounces.
You may have noticed I said
we have four drink sizes
that only showed you three.
That's because on Subway's
catering menu in the US
you'll find this, thank you
to my beautiful assistant.
It's a gallon of Hubert's Lemonade.
This supposedly serves eight people,
which would be 16 fluid ounces each.
Why is the recommended
serving size for this lemonade
smaller than the usual small size
that's very suspicious Subway,
but I do love this lemonade.
So the large is supposed to be 40 ounces.
We're gonna measure it
to see if I'm being lied to basically
The medium is meant to
contain 473 milliliters
of your drink.
Let's see how much is actually in there.
The coke is really dark
so it's kind of hard for
me to see the numbers
but it did go slightly above 32 ounces
which is significantly less
than the 40 I was promised.
And by the way, this was with no ice.
It's meant to be 473 milliliters
but I just wanted wanted
to show you look how
much is missing from the top.
This here is about 425
ish and if that's the case
it's missing over 50
milliliters of my soda.
What gives Subway?
Here's everything that you'll find
at Subway China that you
won't find in the US.
Here's everything that you'll find
at a US Subway that you
won't find in China.
Obviously Subway's menu
is highly customizable
by combining different ingredients.
Subway claims, you can create
over 2 million sandwiches.
I don't know if I believe that
but I also don't have the
time and or money to prove it.
So let's just say it's true.
Now let's start with the
foundation of any sandwich.
The bread.
Now here in China we have
a couple of options and
by a couple, I mean two that
you don't have in the US.
First is honey oat
and the second is parmesan oregano.
Now it's on the menu
but of all of the stores
that we ordered from
they all changed out the parmesan oregano
for just regular bread.
So I don't know if they're
offering it anymore
or it's just still on the menu
and they've forgotten to take it out.
And in the US we also have
exclusive bread options
like artisan flatbread
and hardy multi-grain.
Once you've picked your bread
then it's time to choose your fillings.
These are all of China's
exclusive fillings
that you won't find in the US
starting with the black
pepper thick cut steak.
Oh, they weren't joking
when they said thick cut.
Oh yeah, that's pretty decent.
Here we have the Italian sausage
and the chicken thigh chop.
It's always the chicken
thigh when it comes
to chicken meat in a burger
because Chinese people's
thigh is the juicy part
not the breast.
Next we've got the egg mayo series.
We love our egg mayo here.
We've got salami, egg mayo.
I will need to ask for
more salami next time.
Four pieces just doesn't cut it
when you've got a six inch sub.
There's also the tuna egg mayo.
I'm just gonna move swiftly onto
the chicken teriyaki egg mayo.
The Chinese name is quite descriptive.
It's the "Parent and Child" sandwich
because obviously chicken and egg.
Put egg mayo in a bun, I'm happy.
Here we've got the
teriyaki chicken sandwich
on honey oat bread.
It's not got egg mayo in it.
It's an inferior teriyaki chicken.
The full house, which is tuna and chicken.
Oh, it's a good thing none of you
can smell my breath right now. Woo!
And here we've just got
the bog standard ham.
Save the best for last our
pulled pork limited edition sandwich
with chia seeds in our bread.
I'm quite pleased with the amount of meat
that's found its way into the Subway Subs.
A little bit too sweet for my taste
but the pulled pork is there.
We have a ton of subs
in the US that aren't on the Chinese menu.
So let's start with
the classic sandwiches.
So we've got the big hot
pastrami, buffalo chicken,
chicken and bacon ranch, cold cut combo
meatball marinara oven
roasted Turkey and ham,
steak and cheese and the veggie patty.
A fast food meatball sub sounds difficult
so I kind of wanna try
it and see how it tastes.
This is a very heavy
sandwich I just want to say.
It reminds me of school lunch
like the smell of walking into a cafeteria
when you're in like seventh grade.
That's the vibe I'm getting from it.
It's an okay meatball sub.
So this is the Chicken Bacon Ranch.
I love chicken, I love
bacon and I love ranch.
So hopefully I like the sandwich.
There's just something
about how the meat looks
that's making my tummy hurt a little.
I think it's just the paleness
of the chicken and bread.
I mean it tastes better than it looks.
Next we have the no bready bowls
starting with the black pepper steak
egg mayo, no bready bowl.
This actually looks really good.
They've got some kidney beans
and some kind of coarse
grain at the bottom as well.
This actually looks decent.
Oh yeah, now this tastes really good.
Next we have the tuna
egg mayo, no bready bowl.
Oh that does not look appetizing.
So teriyaki chicken egg
mayo, no bready bowl
but this is actually pretty decent.
I think the no bready bowls
are probably actually I'd order again.
We also have the no bready bowls which
according to the menu are
different than a salad
although they look exactly like a salad
A salad hidden under a
mountain of deli meats.
Here are all of the US
exclusive bready bowls.
The exclusive sandwiches don't stop there.
In 2022, Subway in the US launched a range
of menu items known as the Subway series.
It's a list of 12 subs
with predetermined ingredients
designed to streamline
the ordering process.
So instead of going down the line
and picking every individual
thing that you want
you can just order these off a menu.
While prepping for this shoot,
we thought we had most of the
subs on the Subway series menu
but since then we have found out
that they have dropped more
sandwiches on this menu.
The list just seems to keep growing
and I don't know when they're gonna stop.
So let's just focus on the subs
that we have in front of us right now.
I am very intrigued by the monster.
That name sounds awful
and I'm hoping the sandwich will not be.
I think it looks pretty good to me.
Okay, so this is the monster
which is steak, bacon, and cheddar.
That's delicious and good.
The Bella Mozza.
I think that if I was any of
the sandwiches on this list
I would want to be this one because
why wouldn't I want to be
the prettiest sandwich?
This one definitely has like
a more pleasing look to it.
There's just like so much color in it.
It looks like it has a lot
of fresh ingredients in it.
So in the Bella Mozza we have
ham, capacola and mozzarella.
All delicious. Let's taste it.
Oh no.
And I really, really like it.
This feels very classic sandwich to me.
Like if I was going to a sandwich shop,
I'd probably order something like this.
So this is the All American,
which has turkey, ham and bacon.
She looks pretty good.
She's not really giving, I
think it's too much onions.
I really, really wanna taste
the sliced avo Mexicali.
This one has rotisserie
chicken, avocado and pepper jack
that all sounds so good to me.
Ooh, she's saucy.
I feel like I haven't
seen much sauce going on.
So this is different.
There's a lot of sauce in there.
It's good but I think the sandwich has
just been sitting here for so
long that the bread got soggy.
So the bread on the bottom
is like very, very soft
but the actual taste of the sandwich
is really, really good.
It's honestly tasty.
And Subway also offers wraps.
So here we've got the
black pepper steak wrap.
Oh yeah, I think I prefer this version.
Mm. Next we have the
teriyaki chicken wrap.
Smells a bit wet.
The Turkey breast wrap
there's literally one
slice of Turkey breast.
Here we have the Italian sausage wrap.
The sausage has been butterflied.
It's just one sausage.
It's actually okay.
After doing all of this Subway research
they actually added wraps onto our menu.
Here are all of the wraps that
you can get on the US menu.
We also have a couple
of exclusive meat options in
the US pepperoni and capacola.
Here in China we have some
meaty toppings that you
won't find in the us.
For example, shrimp
which they literally
gave us in a paper bag.
Subway will ask you if you
want cheese on your sub
and we definitely have a
lot more cheese options
than they have in China.
Both countries offer American
or shredded mozzarella
but the US also offers
pepper jack, provolone
swiss or monterey cheddar.
China has one sandwich topping
that you won't find in the
US and that's egg mayo.
We love egg mayo here.
I love egg mayo.
It's basically just chunky mayo
with eggs inside and you'll find it
in over half of our
offerings here in China.
Subway, you have it in subs, you have it
in wraps and you have it
in protein bowls as well.
All of these are egg mayo.
It's delicious.
When it comes to vegetable
toppings, both the US
and China offer tomatoes,
lettuce, cucumber, pickles
green pepper, black olives,
red onions and jalapenos.
But the US also carries banana peppers
my favorite spinach and avocado.
We also have some exclusive sauces
like barbecue and
thousand island dressing.
And then there's also mayo, honey mustard
black pepper sauce and olive oil.
It's kind of shocking that
we don't have thousand
island dressing as an option.
It's not like a super
common sandwich spread
at least not in my house.
But you do see it on
Rubens and stuff like that.
Exclusive sauces in the US include oil
red wine vinegar, creamy
sriracha, buffalo sauce,
MVP Parmesan vinegarette
and roasted garlic aioli.
They shove these words in everywhere.
You guys are like trying to gaslight me
into thinking that this is like
an athlete's favorite food.
And I know that's not true.
It's crazy. It's crazy
what's happening here.
MVP Parmesan vinaigrette isn't real.
You made that up.
Speaking of trying to make me think
that athletes love Subway,
here are the athlete collabs.
Here we have the avocado
spike bowl by Rob Gronkowski.
The No Look Chicken by Patrick Mahomes.
The Front Court Feast by Charles Barkley
the Meatball Marksman by Steph Curry.
And then there's the Danger Witch.
Let's talk about the Danger witch.
Once upon a time
this was Russell Wilson's
Subway collab sandwich.
I don't know what happened but
at some point they removed
his name from the sandwich.
I think it has something to do with
this weird commercial they did
promoting the Danger Witch.
You ever done anything dangerous?
I obviously can't confirm anything
but I'm dying to try this.
So let's see what the
danger witch tastes like.
They probably should get rid of it
in general 'cause it's also
just not a very good sandwich.
It mostly just tastes like mustard.
Now it's tradition on
Food Wars to combine all
of one country's exclusives together.
I present to you the US only sub.
It has bacon, pepper jack
cheese, banana peppers, spinach
buffalo sauce, all on
jalapeno cheddar bread.
I think our specific Subway didn't have
This is their other cheesy bread
but it's the closest thing we got.
It mostly just tastes like
bacon, which I'm not upset about.
This is the China only sub
black pepper steak, egg mayo
thousand island dressing
on honey oat bread.
Let's see if you guys in
the states are missing out.
You know egg mayo goes
on absolutely anything
and the thick cut steak
gives it a nice oomph.
Yeah, I'd order this again
Now let's see what side
options we have in the US.
Chips in general seem to
be more of a US exclusive.
Here are all of the flavors
I was able to get my hands
on at our location.
So we have three lay's flavors.
There's sour cream and
onion, classic and barbecue.
We also have two baked Lays flavors.
The original and barbecue.
We have Doritos in both
cool ranch and nacho cheese.
Two flavors of Miss Vicky's chips.
We have jalapeno and spicy dill pickle
and we have three flavors of Sun Chips.
We have garden salsa
original and harvest cheddar.
You can also get a go-go squeeze
applesauce as a kid's side.
Subway also has sides,
namely Ratan pepper popcorn chicken.
So I would assume that
this is meant to be
Szechwanese style chicken
in that it should be spicy
and also make your mouth pleasantly numb.
Just the tiniest hint of chili heat.
Here we've got some potato balls.
It just tastes like hash browns.
Now this is pretty unique.
This is called Western region
style roast chicken wings.
Usually when you say something
is Western region flavored
they usually mean lamb or cumin.
No, that was pretty good.
No potato chips here.
We're super healthy,
but we do have cookies.
Now both the US and China
each have an exclusive cookie.
Here in China we have the peach oolong.
Hmm, that's quite pleasant.
And Subway in the US offers
the raspberry cheesecake cookie.
I love Subway cookies.
They are surprisingly soft
and definitely the best cookie
in fast food in my opinion.
I just think that they're so good.
It's amazing as I suspected.
And finally we have drinks.
I am very happy that Subways
in the US carry Coke products.
You can get a classic Coca-Cola
a little DC, Sprite, Dasani,
which not my favorite.
Vitamin Water XXX, Gold Peak Sweet Tea
Simply lemonade, orange or apple.
Honest Kids Superfruit
Punch or a Hubbert Lemonade.
For drinks, China carries
soy milk and PepsiCo products
so you can get Pepsi,
Pepsi Light 7Up Tropicana.
You can also get Aquafina water
and it's soda water variety,
but I guess only in select stores
because when we ordered we ended up
getting full spring, which is kind of
like the Chinese version
of Evian I would say.
Now Subway entered China
relatively late in 2005
and I believe nationwide
they've got about 700 stores.
When they first opened
they had a lot more
presence than they do now.
They've kind of slid into obscurity
and they're only really found
in major cities like Beijing and Shanghai.
Sandwiches aren't really hot in China.
People don't like cold
bread, cold sandwiches
of course you can ask for
your sandwich to be heated up
but just the fact that it's kind of a
a cold sandwich as a default
is a bit of a turnoff.
I think you can tell there
hasn't been much localization
on the Subway menu.
I mean there's the egg mayo,
there's the Western region chicken,
but cold custom made sandwiches
are not really the
first thing you think of
when you want food in China.
You can probably guess
that Subway's in a bit
of a sad state here in China.
In terms of competition,
I mean there's no need to
even try to compete with KFC, Mackey D.
They're so far ahead, completely
left Subway in the dust.
Now let's see, which country
is getting their subs for less.
A foot long Italian BMT
from a Chinese Subway
costs 47 Yuan, that's $6.79
At the time of recording
a foot long Italian BMT
from a US Subway costs $9 99.
I was so curious as to what BMT means
and it apparently stands for
biggest meatiest, tastiest.
I don't know if I like that.
That makes the US sandwich
this much more expensive.
Subway pricing has been
a contentious subject
in the US for a while now.
You guys might remember
the infamous $5 foot long promotion
Subway operated for a really long time.
It was pulled after franchisees
said it was costing them too much money.
Subway has repeatedly
attempted to bring it back
but it's been quickly
killed every single time.
I have a feeling that US Subway
will be more unhealthy
than China's Subway.
So let's compare a classic Turkey sub.
A six inch oven roasted Turkey sub
in the US is 270 calories.
Now Subway China hasn't
released its nutritional information,
but based on independent
third party research
I can tell you that
a six inch oven roasted turkey sub
here in China is 252 calories
or 270 depending on who you talk to.
The most calorific sandwich you can get is
the Chicken and Bacon Ranch,
which clocks in at 570 calories.
I wanna guess the most caloric
sandwich in Subway China.
I think it has to be the
black pepper thick cut steak.
Am I right?
Close? A six inch black pepper
thick cut is 415 calories,
but our heaviest hitter is in fact
the six inch tuna sandwich
clocking in at 450 calories.
Not only is it not tasty, it's
also incredibly calorific.
Is it in my food or not?
Is it, like, touching the food?
Is it in the gloves?
Is it in the hats?
Is it in this little crown
that I've been wearing all day?
I'm so stressed out.